İyi akşamlar arkadaşlar. 8 Ocak 2025 Çarşamba günü 54. ders günümüz saat 19.30. 1 dersimize başlıyoruz.
Kaldığımız yerden devam edeceğiz. Ses ya da görüntüde problem olursa bildirin lütfen değerli arkadaşlar.
Şimdi biraz konuyu değiştireceğiz. Geçen dersimizin hatta son iki dersimizin konusu smart pointers. Akıllı pointer sınıflarıydı.
Bugün ilk önce literal operators konusunu göreceğiz. Türkçe belki en uygun karşılık programcı tarafından oluşturulan sabitler.
Aslında ilginç bir function overloading biçimi özür dilerim operatör overloading biçimi biz bir sabit yazar gibi bir notasyonla bir ifade oluşturuyoruz.
Derleyici bu ifadeyi bir fonksiyon çağrısına dönüştürüyor. İşte burada çağrılan fonksiyona literal operator function demek yaygın.
Arkadaşlar böylece sınıf türünden sabitlermiş gibi ifadeleri kullanabiliyoruz.
Belirli bir kalıba sığdırmak zor. Sadece şu işe yarıyor diyemem. Çünkü olanakları başlangıçta görünenden daha fazla.
Ama standart kütüphane string sınıfında, string view sınıfında, krono kütüphanesinde ve birkaç yerde daha örneğin kompleks sınıfında literal operators kullanıyor.
Hem standart kütüphane kullanıyor hem de biz de kendi fonksiyonlarımızı yazarak belirli kurallara uygun şekilde kendi fonksiyonlarımızı yazarak kendi literal operator, literal operatörlerimizi oluşturabiliriz.
Arkadaşlar konuya şöyle ayrıntılı bir giriş yapmadan önce sabitler konusunu bir hatırlatmak istiyorum.
Evet belki kursun başında çok az değinmiş olabilirim ama daha çok C kursunda detaylı anlattığımı C kursuna katılan arkadaşlar hatırlayacaklar.
Arkadaşlar normalde sabitler C ve C++ dillerinde temel olarak iki kategoriye ayrılıyor.
İki dildeki terminoloji birbiriyle tamamen aynı olmasa da benzer.
Mesela iki dilde de tam sayı sabitleri gerçek sayı sabitleri var.
Fakat C++ dili arkadaşlar literal terimini kullanırken C dili daha doğrusu C dili standartı constant terimini kullanıyor.
Sabitlere ilişkin tam sayı ve gerçek sayı sabitlerine ilişkin bilmeniz gerekenleri muhakkak biliyorsunuz ya da belki kat ayrıntı dışında biliyor olabilirsiniz.
Ama sadece hatırlatmak için birkaç tane örnek verelim.
Bir, bir tam sayı sabiti onluk, onaltılık, sekizlik sayı sisteminde yazılabilir.
C'de ikilik sayı sisteminde yazma yok.
C++ dilinde 0B ya da 0B önekiyle arkadaşlar ikilik sayı sisteminde de sabit yazılabiliyor.
Modern C++ sayı eklendi ama Modern C++'dan önce de yerleyiciler extension olarak, eklenti olarak tam sayı sabitlerinin ikilik sayı sisteminde de yazımına izin veriyorlardı.
Arkadaşlar sadece bir hatırlatma konuyu detaylı anlatmayacağım demiştim.
Son ekler, tam sayı sabitinin ya da gerçek sayı sabitinin yazımında kullanılan son ekler, İngilizcesiyle suffix, sabitin türünü belirlemede temel rolü oynuyor.
Örneğin 35 int türden bir sabit iken 35U ya da 35 büyük harf U unsight int türden 35L ya da küçük harf L long türden UL, LU ikisi de olabilir.
Küçük harf büyük harf kullanabilirsiniz.
Unsight long türden L ile yine büyük harf ve küçük harf kullanabilirsiniz.
Long long türden LLU ya da UL ile unsight long long türden sabitler.
Tabi ki bunlar çok çok önemli özellikle function overloading konusunda düşünsenize örneğin full fonksiyonla bu şekilde çağrı yapmakla bu şekilde çağrı yapmak arasında eğer full overload edilmişse function overload resolution ile hangi fonksiyonu seçileceği kullandığımız sabitin türüyle belirleniyor.
Gerçek sayı sabitlerinde ise nokta içeren sabitler hatırlayalım doğrudan double türdendir.
Efendim float türden sabit olması için hem nokta içermesi hem de son ek olarak küçük harf ya da büyük harf P F son ekini alması gerekiyor.
Nokta içermeden L'ye içerirse long türden sabit fakat nokta içerip L son ekine sahip olursa A arkadaşlar long double türden sabit oluyor idi.
Ama bakın şimdi mesela string başlık dosyasını dahil etsem ve ilgili using bildirimlerini yapsam örneğin using arkadaşlar stood literals.
Ben Ahmet yanına küçük harf S ekini koyduğumda aslında arkadaşlar bir ne oluşturmuş oluyorum bir literal operator ifadesi oluşturmuş oluyorum.
Peki bu durumda using demişim namespace yazmamışım sizde söylemiyorsunuz her zamanki gibi suç sizde bende değil.
Evet arkadaşlar bu durumda aslında bir fonksiyonun çağrılması sonucunu doğuruyor.
Çağrılan fonksiyon ismiyle de çağrılabilir aslında ama tabi ismiyle çağırdığımızda fazla bir fayda sağlamayacak.
Aslında arkadaşlar şöyle bir fonksiyonu çağırıyoruz.
Bu fonksiyona bir argüman ya da birden fazla argüman gönderiyoruz.
Böylece örneğin bu örnek için konuşuyorum.
Doğrudan stood string ismini kullanmadan bir son ek kullanarak onu adeta bir sabitmişçesine kullanma şansına sahip oluyoruz.
Yalnız buradaki literal terimine dikkat edelim.
Mesela şöyle bir kod yazsam oto s eşittir ahmet s.
Burada bir fonksiyon çağrısı var.
Peki şunu deneyelim arkadaşlar.
Kunst eksperi oto s eşittir ahmet s.
Bakın derliyorum arkadaşlar.
C++ standartının ne olduğuna bağlı olarak herhangi bir şekilde bir sentaks hatası olmadığını görüyorsunuz.
Yani literal operatör fonksiyonları const eksperi fonksiyon olabilir ya da olmayabilir.
Bu fonksiyonun ne şekilde tanımlandığına bağlı.
Arkadaşlar yine henüz görmesek de ilerleyen haftalarda göreceğimiz göremezsek ileri C++'da göreceğimiz göremezsek ahirette diyeceğim artık göreceğimiz bir de string view sınıfı var.
Bakın orada da bir ne var arkadaşlar bir using şurayı silelim bir literal operatör fonksiyonu var.
Efendim bu sefer bunun yanına s v son ekini koyduğum zaman yine operatör s v fonksiyonu çağrılıyor.
Deniz'in sorusu oto yazınca biz fark etmeden string oluşup başka bir değere conversion gerçekleşebilir mi yoksa illa da string demek midir?
İlla string demek çünkü çağrılan fonksiyonun birazdan göstereceğim geri dönüş değeri türü string.
Yani burada oto type deduction ile string elde etmemizin nedeni fonksiyon çağrısından elde edilen ifade söz konusu fonksiyonun geri dönüş değeri still string olduğu için ifadenin türü de string.
Yine krono kütüphanesi henüz görmedik ama ileride göreceğiz.
Yoğun bir şekilde literal operatörleri kullanıyor arkadaşlar.
Arkadaşlar yalnız krono kütüphanesinin kendi namespace'i var.
O namespace'in ismi de krono.
Bakınız using namespace krono.
Örneğin milisaniye değeri kullanmak için arkadaşlar böyle bir sonic.
Efendim mikrosaniye kullanmak için ya da nanosaniye kullanmak için literal operatörleri kullanabiliyoruz.
Hocam bazı stringlerin başına L'ye koyuyorduk.
Aslında ben kısmen C'de anlatıyorum.
Kısmen C++'da.
İsterseniz bir derste ona değineyim ama şimdi girmeyeyim.
Winup ile mi alakalı?
Hayır.
Winup ile alakalı.
Doğrudan Winup ile alakalı değil.
Arkadaşlar.
Char türü.
Wchar underscore t türü.
Yani karakterleri ilişkin bazı türleri bilmemiz.
Belki tekrar etmemiz gerekiyor.
Ona inşallah başka bir derste değineriz.
Char Vey.
Efendim şimdi şunu anlatmaya çalıştım.
Literal operatörler modern C++'la birlikte C++'ın standart kütüphanesinde birçok yerde karşımıza çıkıyor.
Örneğin string, string view ya da krononun duration isimli türleri söz konusu olduğunda
bu türden değerleri kullanmak için elimizde tek olanak olmasa da olanaklardan biri literal operatörleri kullanmak.
Fakat konuyu biraz ilginç, biraz daha zor, biraz daha olanak sağlayan, olanak veren yönden bakarsak konuya kendi literal operatörlerimizi tanımlayabiliyoruz.
Ya da kullanacağınız kütüphaneler sizin işinizi kolaylaştırmak için literal operatör fonksiyonları size verebiliyorlar.
Örneğin biz date kütüphanemiz vardı ödev halen de burada bir arkadaşımın yaptığı gayet güzel ödevin kodları da var.
İmplementasyonu var.
Örneğin date sınıfında ben tabi kurallara uygun şekilde bir fonksiyon tanımlayarak arkadaşlar örneğin şöyle bir ifadenin
çift tırnak içinde 10, 0, 5, 1987 date türünden nesne gösteren bir ifade olmasını sağlayabilirim.
Yani kendi literal operatör fonksiyonlarımı kendim oluşturabilirim.
Fakat burada uyulması gereken bazı kurallar var.
Şimdi o kurallar çok detaylı olduğu için hepsini tek tek anlatmak yerine en son cppreference.com'da ilgili sayfayı göstereceğim.
Fakat oraya gelmeden şimdilik şunu söyleyelim.
Kısıtlamalar fonksiyonların parametre değişkenlerinin türleri üstünde.
Örneğin böyle bir fonksiyonu literal operatör fonksiyonunu double parametreye sahip bir fonksiyon olarak yazamazsınız.
Ya da float parametreye sahip bir fonksiyon olarak yazamazsınız.
Ya da int parametreye sahip bir fonksiyon olarak yazamazsınız.
Yani fonksiyonun, yazacağımız operatör fonksiyonunun parametri yapısının geri dönüş değeri sizin opsiyonunuzda.
İstediğiniz bir geri dönüş değeri kullanabilirsiniz.
Ama parametre değişkeni ya da değişkenlerinin türü konusunda fısıtlamalara uyumak zorundasınız.
Az önce söylediğim gibi yazacağınız fonksiyon const expr olabilir ya da olmayabilir.
Tabii ki const expr olmasıyla olmaması arasındaki fark fonksiyonu çağıran ifadeyi yazdığımızda örneğin şöyle bir ifade yazsam bu ifadenin constant expression olup olmadığını belirliyor.
Böylece bu ifadeden faydalanarak const expr bir değişken tanımlayabilir miyim, tanımlayamaz mıyım onu belirliyor.
Şimdi hemen birinci kuraldan bahsedelim.
Arkadaşlar az önceki örneklerden gördüğünüz üzere örneğin bir string nesnesi kullanmak için kullandığım son eke bakın underscore yok.
Standart kütüphane doğrudan arkadaşlar underscore olmayan son ekleri kullanıyor ve underscore olmayan yani alt tire karakteriyle başlamayan son ekler standart kütüphane için rezerve edilmiş durumda.
Siz kendi yazdığınız fonksiyonlara böyle isim veremezsiniz.
Dolayısıyla sizin yazdığınız fonksiyonlara örtülü olarak çağrı yapan kod bu şekilde örneğin bir sabit ifadesi oluşturamaz.
Arkadaşlar underscore olmak zorunda.
Hadi gelin ilk örneğimizi yazalım.
Arkadaşlar şimdi bakın ben metrik sistemde metre, kilometre, efendim santimetre, Türkçe söylüyorum tabii, santimetre bazen İngilizce mi söyleyeyim, Türkçe mi söyleyeyim karıştırıyorum.
Ana dili Türkçe olmayan arkadaşlarımız da var kursa metre, kilometre, santimetre gibi değerlere karşılık gelen aslında user defined literallar oluşturmak isteyeyim.
Arkadaşlar birinci kural burada iki ayrı mekanizma var.
Bakın en fazla kafa karıştıran yer burası.
User defined literallar İngilizce karşılığıyla cooked ya da uncooked olabilir.
Yani bilmem ki Türkçe'ye nasıl çevirmeli.
Pişmiş, pişmemiş desek biraz komik oluyor.
Arkadaşlar hazır gelen, gelmeyen belki daha iyi bir seçenek olabilir.
Arkadaşlar cooked olması ya da olmaması şu demek.
Örneğin biz şöyle bir ifade kullandığımızda, lütfen dikkat, diyelim ki 53.521 underscore m buradaki fonksiyon cooked olarak yazılmışsa, o zaman ilgili fonksiyona arkadaşlar buradaki sabit, örneğin bu double türden sabit, doğrudan argüman olarak geçiliyor.
Yani burada argüman olarak geçilen, buraya dikkat arkadaşlar, son ekten önceki sabitin kendisi.
Yani bu bir tam sayı sabitiyse, tam sayı fonksiyonun tam sayı alacak parametresine argüman olarak gönderiliyor.
Bu bir gerçek sayıysa, bu örnekte olduğu gibi yazılmış fonksiyonun gerçek sayı türden, long double türden parametresine argüman olarak gönderiliyor.
Yine aynı şekilde örneğin, örneğin eğer bir önceki örnekte olduğu gibi 23.05.1987 underscore dt.
Eğer bu cooked olarak yazılmışsa, arkadaşlar bu adres, yani string literalinin dönüştüğü adres, fonksiyonun adres alacak parametresine argüman olarak geçiliyor.
Ya da bakınız, şöyle bir fonksiyon çağrısı yapmışsam, karakter sabiti, İngilizce ise character literal olan, türü char olan, tek tırnak içindeki a, ilgili fonksiyona argüman olarak geçiliyor.
Ve burada parametre, örneğin charterden.
Ama uncooked olması durumunda, sizin göndereceğiniz, arkadaşlar bakın bakın burası biraz tuhaf.
Diyelim ki uncooked bir fonksiyon var.
Ve siz ikilik sayı sisteminde yazılmış, bir tam sayı olarak kullanılacak, böyle bir ifade kullandığınızda, buraya dikkat edin, çift tırnak var mı?
Sonek öncesinde yazdığım yazıda çift tırnak karakteri var mı?
Yok.
Fakat buna rağmen, kural gereği uncooked olduğunda, derleyicinin oluşturduğu kodda, derleyici bu yazıyı çift tırnak içine alıyor ve fonksiyona bu adresi gönderiyor.
Burayı anladık mı?
Dolayısıyla bu durumda, aslında ilgili fonksiyonda siz bu yazıyı, null karakter görene kadar karakter karakter dolaşabilirsiniz örneğin.
Yani cooked olmasıyla olmaması arasındaki fark ne?
Derleyicinin öneki, olduğu gibi önek diyorum, son ekten önceki yazıyı, olduğu gibi bir sabit ya da bir tam sayı sabiti, bir karakter sabiti, bir gerçek sayı sabiti, bir adres sabiti gibi fonksiyona argüman olarak mı gönderiyor?
Yoksa arkadaşlar onu çift tırnak olmamasına rağmen çift tırnak içine alıp mı fonksiyona böyle bir yazı olarak gönderiyor?
O zaman biz ilk önce cooked olanları görelim.
Çünkü çoğunlukla zaten cooked olanları kullanıyoruz.
Sonra da uncooked olanlara örnek verelim.
Arkadaşlar bakınız, önce fonksiyonun isminden başlayalım.
Operatör çift tırnak olmak zorunda.
Ondan sonra fonksiyonun ismi.
Fakat fonksiyonun isminde underscore ilk karakter olmak zorunda.
Mesela underscore m metre için.
Gerçek sayı alacaksa fonksiyonun parametresi long double olmak zorunda.
Yani renki en büyük olan gerçek sayı türü.
Fonksiyonun geri dönüş değeri türünün ne olacağı tamamen sizin tasarımıza bağlı.
Siz ne isterseniz o olabilir.
Mesela ben fonksiyonumun geri dönüş değerinin türünü double türü yapayım.
Arkadaşlar takip edebiliyor muyuz?
Evet gördüğünüz gibi fonksiyonun geri dönüş değeri türü double.
Benim burada ortak birimim metre olsun.
Dolayısıyla bu gerçekten gerçek sayı olarak metreye karşılık gelsin.
Aslında şunu yazmak istiyorum.
Returnal var.
Ama tabi burada narrowing conversion olduğu için
long double'dan double'a
arkadaşlar hepinizin bildiği gibi
İngilizce karşılığıyla narrowing conversion olduğu için
tipik olarak bunu bilerek isteyerek yazsanız dahi
hem derleyicinin uyarı mekanizmasını tetikleyecek
hem de kodu okuyanlar bunu yanlışlıkla yazmış olduğunuzu düşünebilecekler.
O yüzden şüphesiz böyle durumlarda
örtülü narrowing conversion yerine
typecast operator kullanmalıyız değil mi?
Static cast
efendim double
operatörümüzün operandı var.
Şimdi artık bakınız burayı çok iyi anlamamız gerekiyor.
Ben bu fonksiyona çağrı yapmak için
A
tabi ki tercih edeceğim yol
gerçek sayı sabitini yazıp
sonuna underscore M'ye koymak
böylece double türden bir ifade oluşturmuş oluyorum.
Ya da
eğer çok çok özel bir durum varsa
örneğin ders anlatmak gibi
o zaman fonksiyonu
ismiyle
operatör
çift tırnak
underscore M
ismini yazıp fonksiyonu
argüman olarak
argümanı gönderebilirim.
tabi kim böyle kullanmak ister ki?
Espriyi anladınız mı?
Yalnız bir şeye dikkat edin.
Hadi şimdi fonksiyonumuzu yazdık.
Arkadaşlar
gerçek sayı sabitimizi de koyduk.
ve bir değişken tanımladık.
İster şöyle yazın.
Demin arkadaşımın sorusu
bununla ilgiliydi.
İster
şöyle yazın.
Mesela
auto
distance
eşittir
3.4
M
Arkadaşlar
burada
distance isimli değişkenin
türü ne?
Söyleyin bakalım
Cevap
tabi ki
double
bravo
tabi ki
double
peki
distance değişkeninin
türü double
bu
const expr
değişken olabilir mi?
Cevap
hayır.
Çünkü
bu bir
constant expression
değil.
Ama bakın
fonksiyonun
const expr
olmasını
engel olan
herhangi bir durum
söz konusu değilse
ki o kısıtlamalarda
çok çok azaldı
C++
standardı ile
doğrudan
arkadaşlar
fonksiyonu
const expr
yapabiliriz.
Const expr
yaptığımızda
artık
initializing expression
ilk değer veren ifade
bir constant expression
olduğu için
artık
const expr
anahtar
sözcüğü ile
bir değişken
tanımlayabilirim.
Const expr
variable
oluşturabilirim.
Ama bakın
sadece
bunu
oluşturmakla
yetinmek zorunda
değilim.
işin güzel tarafı
mesela
santimetre içinde
cm
son ikini
kullanarak
santimetre
değerini
doğrudan
yazmak istesem
o zaman
yine
double
operator
çift tırnak
underscore
cm
yine fonksiyonun
parametresi
long
double
bu kez de
arkadaşlar benim
metrik birimin
burada
metre olduğuna göre
santimetrede
metrenin
%1
olduğuna göre
o zaman
yine fonksiyonumuzu
const expr
yapalım
o zaman
bunun da
geri dönüş
değeri
ne olmalı
arkadaşlar
yazamadık
const expr
evet
bunun da
geri dönüş
değeri ne olmalı
val bölüğü
arkadaşlar
ama
yine
static cast
double
bunu
return ifadesi
yapayım
efendim birkaç örnek
daha verelim
mesela
milimetre
ne güne duruyor
öyle değil mi
bizim bir de
milimetremiz de var
ilk okulda
öğrenmiştik
evet
underscore
mm
bu da
val bölü
peki
arkadaşlar
mesela
desimetre
olabilir
değil mi
desimetre de
onda biriydi
değil mi
evet
mesela bu da
desimetre olsun
ama
örneğin
kilometre bile
olabilir
kilometre içinde
hadi
km
son ikini
kullanalım
ama
burada
artık
ne yapmamız
gerekiyor
val
çarpı
değil mi
bir kilometre
arkadaşlar
metre olduğu için
ama şimdi
bakın
artık
doğrulan
şöyle ifadeler
yazabileceğim
mesela
0.0765
kilometre
artı
efendim
23.48
metre
artı
298.12
desimetre
ve bu halen bir sabit ifadesi
artı
1987.1
underscore
milimetre
artı
peki
kalsın bu kadar
ve bakın
auto
distance
arkadaşlar
eşittir
şimdi
bölme yerine
çarpma
kullanmalıydık
nerede
hangisinde
yanlış yazdım
Cengizhan
desimetre
yok
bölme
doğru
yanlış yazmadım
şimdi bakın
benim birimim
metre ya
arkadaşlar
milimetre
metrenin binde biri değil mi
o zaman bu kadar metre oluyor
Cengizhan
anlaşıldı mı
yani
şimdi
bu kadar milimetre
bunun
binde biri kadar metre
yani buradaki birimlerin
hepsi metre
yani buradaki
distance
aslında
değer olarak ne
metre
şimdi belki
anlaşılmıştır
evet
arkadaşlar bakın
constexperi
österik
auto
distance
eşittir
zaten
statik olarak
yardımcı programda
bunun
131.7791
metre
olduğunu söylüyor
şimdi burada
ben çoğunlukla
ilerisi
itlas bas kursunda
anlatıyorum ama
aslında
bundan
faydalanarak
daha iyi
olanaklar da var
arkadaşlar
strong type
diyoruz
ama bu dersi
anlatmayacağım
belki konunun sonunda
biraz bahsederim
şimdi burada
bir şey
yanlış anlaşılmasın
her ne kadar
ismi
distance olan
değişken
ya da
şu ifade
kilometre
ifade ediyor
olsa da
double
türden
aslında
metre
değeri
peki
şöyle bir şey
yapma imkanı
var mı
arkadaşlar
kilometrenin
kendisi
bir tür
olsun
metrenin
kendisi
bir tür
olsun
hatta
bu türler
arasında
dönüşümler
olsun
böyle
yapılara
popüler olarak
strong type
deniyor
çoğun olarak
kullanalım
strong types
oraya daha
gelmedi
arkadaşlar
evet
şimdi
bu örnekte
kukta olarak
kullandık
ve fonksiyonun
parametre değişkenini
long double
yaptık
zaten
double yapma
girişiminde
bululsaydık
doğrudan
compile time'da
bir hata
olacaktı
arkadaşlar
yine
biraz
zamanı
oynayıp
bazı örnekleri
yazmak
yerine
çünkü en azından
ilk derste
bu konuyu
bitirmek istiyorum
ikinci derste
ayostream
kütüphanesine
geçmek
istiyorum
mesela
daha önceden
yazdığım
örneklerden
buraya yapıştırabilirim
şuna bakın
arkadaşlar
şimdi
burada
evet bunlar
çok klasik örnekler
yani ben yazdım
diye bana ait
değil
ama
mesela
underscore
c
santigrat
ifade edecek
underscore
fag'de
arkadaşlar
fahrenheit
ifade edecek
aslında
her iki fonksiyonunda
geri dönüş değeri
double
ama az önce
cengiz abi
bey de
haklı
soruyor
sorarken
çünkü o
benim niyetimin
ne olduğuna bağlı
yani ben şimdi
örneğin
15 nokta
underscore
c
dediğimde
bu
santigratsa
diğerlerinin de
santigrata
dönüştürülmesi
için
bunu yazıyorum
böylece
aslında
örneğin
arkadaşlar
değeri
birden fazla
farklı
son ekler için
aslında
ortak birimin
ne yazdığınıza
ve nasıl yazdığınıza
bağlı olarak
santigrat
fahrenheit
vesaire
kelvin
olmasını
sağlayabilirsiniz
hocam
istediğimiz gibi
seçebilir miyiz
operatör
son ekini
evet
ama
underscore
olmak zorunda
dan sonrası
rasul
bey
bildiğimiz
identifier
yani
örneğin şöyle
bir fonksiyon
yazsanız
izleyin
arkadaşlar
fonksiyona
bakın şimdi
long
double
x
underscore
rasul
yani
şaka olarak
tabi ama
santarsı göstermek için
bu geçerli mi
geçerli
ama
underscore
olmasaydı
geçerli
olmayacaktı
anlaşıldı mı
ve burada da
son ek olarak
yine
kullanıcı
underscore
rasulü
kullanmak zorunda
yaz bir şeye
dikkat edelim
arkadaşlar
az önceki örneklere
dikkat eder misiniz
mesela
bakınız
burada
parametre
long double
değil mi
parametre
long double
ise
sabit kısmının da
gerçek sayı
olması gerekiyor
yani ben de bu
ilk defa
c++
diline
eklendiğinde
şöyle kodlar
yazmaya çalışıyordum
mesela
underscore
c
derdeyici
sentaks
hatası
işaretlediği
zaman
biraz
şaşırıyordum
ilk eklendiğinde
tabi artık
biliyoruz
kuralları
çünkü
sabit kısmının da
gerçek sayı
olması gerekiyor
rasul diyor ki
o zaman biz
çok farklı
maksatlar içinde
bu son ekleri
kullanabiliriz
kendim
tabi
zaten
birazdan da
ben onları
göstereceğim
neler neler
yapabiliriz
arkadaşlar
mesela
bakınız
çok dikkatliyse
şöyle bir şey
bile yazabilirim
underscore
print
böyle bir şey
yazabilir miyim
rasul
yazabilirim
örneğin
böyle bir şey
yazdığımda
gerçekten
buradaki
yazıyı
standart
output'a
verebilir mi
verebilir
hatta
izleyin
arkadaşlar
print
mesela 2 kez
yazıyor olsun
print 3
3 kez
yazıyor olsun
yani bunları
dahi
yapabiliriz
evet
tabi tabi
fonksiyon içinde
Alihan bey
diyor ki
fonksiyon içinde
studsea alt nesnesini
kullanabiliriz
arkadaşlar bakın
güzel güzel örnekler
hazırlamışım
ha yalnız
bu arada bir şey
söyleyeyim
şimdi ben
daha önce de
defalarca
söyledim
burada
yazdığım
kodlarda
daha sonra
bunu da neden
anlatıyorum
arkadaşlar
şimdi daha sonradan
yazılmış kodlara
ya da arkadaşım
not almış
bir başkası
bakıyor
o da eleştiriyor
diyor ki
sizin öğretmeninizde
hiçbir şey
bilmiyormuş
burada şöyle
yapılır
aslında
yani dediği
doğru olsa da
ben
odak noktası
neyse
o da
nasıl başka
bir yöne
yöneltmemeniz
için
bazı detayları
atlıyorum
mesela
arkadaşlar
bazen
using
namespace
stud
direktifini
kullanıyorum
normalde
kullanmayacağım
yerde de
kullanıyorum
çünkü
amaç
en kısa
sürede
konunun
kritik noktasını
size aktarmak
mesela az önce
yazdığım
kodları
normalde
yazmazdım
neden
çünkü
namespace
içinde
vermek
doğrusu
burada
isim
çakışması
riski
çok çok
yüksek
o yüzden
normalde
bunların
bir
namespace
içinde
olması
üretim
pratiğinde
uygulama
yapılması
gereken
ki
burada
örneğin
ben
necisimli
namespace
içinde
iki tane
postexpr
found
Mehmet Ali
İkici'nin
sorusu
son derece
güzel
operatörü
jenerik
yazabilir miyiz
yazabiliriz
işte az önce
Mehmet Ali
dedim ya
şöyle bir cümle
söyledim
en son
cppreference.com'a
bakıp
olanakların
neler olduğunu
şöyle bir
özetleyebiliriz
ve
gerçekten
burada
önemli
olanaklardan
biri de
jenerik
olarak
yani bu
fonksiyonu
bir template
olarak
yazma
imkanınızın
da bulunması
ama
tabi ona yönelik
kurallar da
ayrı
arkadaşlar
bakın
şimdi
bu da
çok güzel
kilobaytı
doğrudan
aslında
size t türünden
bir sabit
yazı
olarak
kullanacağım
arkadaşlar
temel birimim
kilobayt
olacak
ama
megabaytta
kilobaytın
1024 katı
değil mi
burada
temel birim
özür dilerim
byte
çünkü görüyorsunuz
1024 de
çarpılmış
ama
megabaytta
1024 kilobayt
aynı şekilde
örneğin
şöyle de
yazabilirdim
hadi bir tane daha
koyalım
operatör
arkadaşlar
gigabyte
bu da
1024 olsun
ve burada
bir şeye
daha dikkat ediyor
mıyız
bu seferde
fonksiyonumuzun
parametresi
unsigned
longlong
örneğin
bu fonksiyonun
parametresini
longlong
türünden
yapma
gelişiminde
bulunsanız
sentaks
hatası
olacak
o yüzden
belirli
parametre
kalıplarına
uymak
zorundayız
deniz
beyin
sorusu
namespace
ekledikten sonra
using namespace
demeden
literalsı
kullanabiliyor
muyuz
yani arkadaşım
şunu soruyor
diyor ki
burada
using namespace
direktifi
olmasaydı
bu
geçerli
olabilir miydi
hayır
yani aslında
kastettiği
burada
ADL
geçerli
olur muydu
hayır
çünkü
fonksiyona aslında
gönderdiğim argüman
arkadaşlar
kendisi
yine
double türden
ya da long
ya da unsigned
türden
deniz
dolayısıyla
fonksiyona gönderdiğim
argüman
bir
namespace
içindeki
bir sınıfa
ilişkin olmadığı
için
burada
ADL
geçerli
olmayacak
Alihan
Bozger
unsigned
long
double
gibi
izin verdiği
kaç parametre
var
onu birazdan
göstereceğim
ama şimdi
hemen ilk
aklıma gelenler
gerçek sayı
türleri için
long
double
tam sayı
türleri için
unsigned
long
ve
char
adresler
için
ya sadece
costchar
yıldız
ya da
costchar
yıldız
virgül
size
underscore
t
iki parametresi
olacak
evet şimdi
buradaki örneğe
geri dönelim
Alihan
arkadaşlar bakın
auto
size
4 kilobyte
aslında bu
size t
türünden
değerinde
bir değişken
burayı anlıyoruz
değil mi
arkadaşlar
bizim değişkenimizin
türü
user defined
type olamıyor
ama
Ozan Bey
fonksiyonun
geri dönüş
değeri türü
user defined
type olabilir
evet
using
byte
eşittir
unsigned
char
yani
unsigned
char'a
eş
isim
olarak
byte
ismini
verdim
bakın
şimdi
bufferları
oluştururken
biraz
yazım
kolaylığı
sağlıyor
array'in
byte
virgül
kilobyte
açılımı
böylece
belki
koda
bakan
burada
doğrudan
kilobyte
değerini
bir
sabit
olarak
yazsaydım
işte
çarpı
belki
kodunu
okunması
biraz daha
problemli
olabilecekti
tabi burada
bunu kullanmak
iyi mi
kötü mü
o tartışılır
ama
ona haklarını
göstermek için
arkadaşlar
şimdi çok dikkatli
izleyin
gelelim
demin
arkadaşlarım
sordu ya
parametreler
ne olabilir
diye
bakın ben size
çok ilginç bir
örnek göstereyim
eğer
parametre
birinci parametre
const
çağrı
yıldızsa
yani
c string
isterse
sonunda
null
karakteri
olan
ikinci parametre
size
t olursa
fonksiyona
string
literaliyle
çağrı
yapabiliyorsunuz
yani
bakınız
çok güzel
bir örnek
gerçekten
date
başlık
dosyasını
dahil
edelim
ve
arkadaşlar
normalde
bunu date
ütmaniyese
muhtemelen
kendi
verecek
operatör
çift
tırnak
underscore
dt
buraya dikkat
hatta
önce
şöyle bir şey
göstereyim
size
bakın
operatör
date
örneğini
daha sonra
verelim
yani
önce
kuralı
görelim
mesela
fonksiyonun
geri dönüş
değeri
int
olsun
ne oldu
önemli değil
operatör
çift
tırnak
underscore
arkadaşlar
necati
ergin
ne
birinci
parametre
const
char
yıldız
p
arkadaşlar
efendim
ikinci parametre
size
underscore
t
size
underscore
tek
muhtemelen
ikinci parametreyi
kullanmayacaksınız
o yüzden
isim vermemek
yaygın
ama ben
arka planda
ne olup bitiyor
onu göstermek
için
ikinci parametreye
de
isim vermeyi
tercih ettim
ve şimdi
bakınız
burada
ilk olarak
stut
cout
arkadaşlar
t adresindeki
yazıyı
yazdırayım
izleyin
ve
ondan sonra da
hatta şöyle
diyelim
neyse böyle
kalsın
ondan sonra da
arkadaşlar
s eşittir
yani buraya
giren
size t
değerini
onu
göstereyim
ama fonksiyonumuz
sadece bunu
göstermeye
yönelik olduğu için
bir değerini
döndürsün
ve şimdi
bu fonksiyonu
çağırıyorum
bakın bakın
fonksiyonu
Ali
Han
underscore
Ne
biçiminde
çağırdım
hatta
geri dönüş değerini de
intürden
bir değişkende
tanımlayayım
tabi ki kodun
hiçbir anlamı
yok
hayatın da
bir anlamı
yok diyorum
şimdi felsefi
tarafa gidip
hayır hayır
öyle demeyeceğim
ama sadece
size
şunu göstermek
istiyorum
bakınız
derliyorum
bakın
adresteki yazı
Ali Han
fakat
s'nin değeri de
altı
demek ki
derleyici
böyle bir
fonksiyon
yazıldığında
aslında
bu halen
cooked mu
cooked
aslında
bunu
fonksiyonun
birinci
parametresine
bir adres
olarak geçiyor
string literalleri
aslında
constjar diziler
fakat
örtülü olarak
adrese dönüşüyor ya
fakat
fonksiyonun
ikinci
parametresine
bu yazının
uzunluğunu
geçiyor
eğer
siz bu
uzunluk
değerini
kod içinde
kullanmayacaksanız
o zaman
arkadaşlar
parametre
yine olmak
zorunda
ama
isim
vermeyin
onu daha önce
konuşmuştuk
şimdi bu
söylediğimden
hareketle
date örneğine
geçelim
operatör
çift tırnak
underscore
dt
fonksiyonun
geri dönüş
değeri
bizim
date türümüz
olsun
hani o
ödevdeki
tür
evet
fonksiyonun
birinci
parametresi
ve ikinci
ikinci parametreyi
kullanmak
istemediğim
için
isim
vermedim
arkadaşlar
zaten
date
sınıfının
constjar yıldız
parametreli
bir
constraktörü
var idi
o zaman
return
date
tabi
constraktör
explicit
muhtemelen
str
şimdi
bakın
mesela
arkadaşlar
izleyin
şöyle bir
kod yazsam
ya da
tabi
burada
kodun doğru
yazıldığını
varsayarak
yazıyorum
underscore
dt
deneyelim
böyle bir
insörterimiz
vardı ya
iostream
maaşlık
dosyasını
inkluat edelim
bakın
mayıs
cumartesi
hatta
şuna ne
dersiniz
tabi
fonksiyonlar
implement edilmemiş
olabilir
ben sınıfı
hatırlamıyorum
kendi yazdığım
kod değil
bir arkadaşımla
ödeyebilir
güzel olduğu
için
buraya aldım
date
my date
arkadaşlar
eksi
efendim
yazılmış gibi
sentaks hatası
vermiyor
hatırlayın
o ödevi
hatırlayan var mı
yapanlar
hatırlar
tabi de
iki tarih
arasındaki
gün farkını
hesaplıyordu
yani
aslında
ikinci
burada
çıkartma
operatörünün
subtraction
sağ operandı
date
ve
burada
çağırılan
fonksiyon
birinci
tarihten
ikinci
tarihin
farkı
olman
günü
istiyordu
ya da
şuna ne dersiniz
int
en
yani
olanakları
işaret etmek
için
bu örnekleri
veriyorum
bu sefer de
tam tersi
mesela
arkadaşlar
tabii
en değerinin
programın
çalışma
zamanında
belirlendiğini
düşünün
artı
en
yani
Haziran
1998'den
en gün
sonrası
olan
tarihi
elde etmiş
oluyorum
bu arada
aklımıza şöyle
bir soru
gelebilir
ki
benim gelmişti
bu konuyu
ilk öğrenirken
necati
oldu ki
bu fonksiyonu
ismiyle
çağıracağım
o zaman
nasıl çağıracağım
son derece
basit
fonksiyonun
ismi değişmiyor
yine aynı kural
operatör
çift tırnak
underscore
dt
yalnız
fonksiyonun
bu durumda
ikinci
iki parametresi
olduğu için
ikinci
parametresine de
argümanı
geçmek
zorundasınız
yani
gerçekten
örneğin
şöyle bir
argüman
geçseydim
ama
gerçekten
işini doğru
yapmasını
istiyorsam
burada
iki tane de
arkadaşlar
dash karakteri
hyphen karakteri
var
o zaman
yazının
uzunluğu
olarak
10 değerini
ekspresifli
argüman olarak
geçmek
zorundayım
anlaşıldı mı
evet
arkadaşlar
örnekleri
çoğaltmak
mümkün
mesela
bu
cppreference.com
anlaşımdan
alınmış örnek
olsa gerek
doğru da
hatırlamıyor
olabilirim
mesela
fonsun
şimdi az önce
Cengiz Hanbey
de aslında
çok güzel bir
saptamada
bulundu
fonsun
isimlendirmesini
de belki
ona uygun
yapmak zorunda
yapmalıyız
demek istedi
o yüzden orada
bir anlam
karmaşıklı oldu
hani bine bölecek
miyim
binine çarpacak
mıyım
ama şimdi bakın
burada diyor ki
sonek
biraz uzun
olsa da
underscore
deck
red
buradaki
radian
bizim
türçemizde
öbürü de
arkadaşlar
derece
yani bu şekilde
yazdığınız zaman
aslında
180 dereceyi
radyana dönüştürmüş
oluyorsunuz
ve elde
ettiğiniz
değer
radyan
değeri oluyor
ama size
ilginç bir
operatör fonksiyonu
daha yazayım
biraz hoşunuza
gidecek
örnekler vereyim
böyle
sınırı
kalmayalım
şuna
bakın
arkadaşlar
söyleyin
bunun türü
ne
cevap
c'de int
c++'da
char
bravo
arkadaşlar ama ben
hem karakter sabiti
kullanmak istiyorum
fakat aynı zamanda
bunun int olarak
yani c'deki gibi
karakter kodu olan
tam sayı olarak
alınmasını istiyorum
bunu yapabilir miyim
yes
nasıl yapabilirim
arkadaşlar son derece basit
bir sarihine
constexpr yapayım
constexpr
int
operatör
çift tırnak
underscore
intin
i'si
tabi
as int
falan gibi
uzun bir isim de
verebilirsiniz
artık
s kalmış
ben
şimdilik örneğimde
underscore
i'deyim
ve parametreyi de
charterden
yapayım
ve
pek yapmam
gereken
arkadaşlar
return
c
demek
zaten
integral
promotion'la
int türüne
yükseltildiğini
biliyorsunuz
yani bu tür
durumlarda
typecast
operatörü
kullanmasanız da
kabul
edilebilir
evet
hesaba
bakın şimdi
see out
stream dahil edilmiş
a
tek tırnak içinde
fakat
a
i
necati bunu
user
kodu yazan
programcı
zaten
int türüne
kest ederek de
yapabilirdi
değil mi
evet tabi ki
ama
olana
göstermek
için
arkadaşlar
bakın şimdi
güzel bir şey
göstereceğim size
uçunuza gidecek mi
bilmiyorum
benim
hoşuma gidiyor
biraz
belki
işin
pantezi kısmı
olabilir
şimdi
söyleyin
bakalım
mehmet
soru
bunun türü ne
türü
const char
köşeli
parantez
altı
ama
array to pointer
conversion ile
array dikey ile
const char
yıldız
türüne
dikey
oluyor
değil mi
ama şöyle
yazarsam
başta da
söylediğim gibi
bu
standart
kütüphaneden
geliyor
aslında
standart
kütüphanedeki
operator double code
s
fonksiyonunu
çağırıyorum ki
bu fonksiyonun
geri dönüş değeri
string
ama şimdi
ne yapacağım
bakın
underscore
s2
bu fikir
bana çok güzel
gelmiş
ben de
başka bir yerde
gördüm
ama
biraz
değiştirdim
tahmin edin
şimdi
ne yapmak
istiyor
burada
olabilir
yani
siz olsanız
buna nasıl
bir anlam
yüklersiniz
böyle
intüatif
olmayan
bir anlam
yüklerseniz
o zaman
çok iyi
bir fikir
değil
belki
ismi
değiştirebiliriz
arkadaşlar
bu durumda
yazı
mehmet
string
olacak
takip edebiliyor
musunuz
yani
mesela böyle
olsa
ali ali
böyle olsa
can can
anladın
nasıl
hatta
bir tane daha
yazıp
s3
bunun
can can
can
stringi
olmasını
sağlayabilirsiniz
peki
nasıl yapacağız
bunu
yine
çift tırnak
içinde
olduğundan
fonksiyonun
birinci parametresine
constrar yıldız
ikinci parametresine
stutzize t
yapacağız
o zaman
bakınız
arkadaşlar
geri dönüş
değeri
stutz
string
olsun
ismi
operator
double
code
underscore
s2
ve fonksiyonun
birinci parametresi
constar
yıldız
str
ikinci parametresi
arkadaşlar
stutzize t
aslında
kodun ne olduğunu
tahmin ediyorsunuz
return
stutz
string
arkadaşlar
st
r
artı
st
r
string
toplanıyordu
değil mi
evet
hatta
hızımızı
alamayıp
bir s3
bir de
s4
oluşturalım
evet
necati
s4
s3
evet
bunu
bunu doğrudan
templit yapamayız
ama ona benzer
şeyler yapabiliriz
evet
ama bunu
doğrudan
bir templit
yapamayız
orada da yapılabilecek
hileler var
str
şimdi bakın
kimin isminden
yapalım
Alihan'ın
ya da
Deniz'in
deniz
eski
s3
deniz
s4
rand
time'a
bakalım
ilginç değil mi
evet
arkadaşlar
şimdi
çok dikkatli
izleyin
buraya kadar
verdiğim bütün örnekler
cooked
idi
yani
pişmiş
ama
şimdi vereceğim
bir örnek
uncooked
şimdi uncooked'da
kural şu
biraz karmaşık
ben de başta
anlamakta biraz zor
çekmiştim
itiraf edeyim
arkadaşlar
uncooked olduğu zaman
siz
çift tırnağı
yani fonksiyonu
çağıran kodu
yazan
programcı
o
yazı kısmını
aslında çift tırnak
kullanmadan yazacak
ama derleyici
onu
fonksiyona
derleyicinin ürettiği kodda
o fonksiyona gönderilirken
tıpkı hani
C'de
stringizing
operatörü var ya
ön işlemci
preprocesör
orada olduğu gibi
çift tırnak içine alacak
yani
ilginç bir kural
örneğin
siz
şöyle bir
arkadaşlar
uncooked
operatör fonksiyonunuz varsa
burada
neyi sağlamış
olacaksınız
aslında diyelim ki
fonksiyonun ismi
operatör
double code
underscore k
fakat fonksiyona
bu tam sayı
gitmiyor
ne gidiyor
ilginç değil mi
bu
string literali
gidiyor
mesela bakın
çok güzel bir örnek
belki çok klasik bir örnek
ama ne yapalım
en güzel örnekler de
klasik örnekler
arkadaşlar
bakın şimdi
normalde
zaten
sentaksımızda
binary literal var
onu
kursun başında
anlatmıştım
ama
olmasaydı
geri dönüş
değeri
arkadaşlar
unsigned
int olan
operatör
double code
underscore b
binary'nin b'si
arkadaşlar
derleyici
bunun
uncooked
olduğunu
nereden
anlayacak
function
over
order
solution'da
fonksiyonun
bir tane
parametresi
olmasından
bakın
burada
size t
parametresi
yok
izleyin
mesela
fonksiyonu
çağırırken de
diyelim ki
auto
x
eşittir
bir sıfır
sıfır
bir
anlaşıldı mı
peki şimdi
bu fonksiyona
ne geldi
arayan
çift tırnak içinde
bir bu yazı
argümanı
olarak geldi
e şimdi
bakın
yani
bu
algoritmayı
herhalde
artık
temel
c düzeyinde
herkes biliyor
değeri
tutacak
bir değişken
olayım
unsight
uval
eşittir
sıfır
şöyle
yazayım
ben daha çok
seviyorum
nal karakter
görene kadar
yazıyı
dolaşalım
while
yıldız p
nal karakteri
olmadığı
sürece
biliyorsunuz
böyle yazmakta
basic c
anlatıyorum
şimdi
tabi hepiniz
biliyorsunuz
şöyle yazmak
aynı anlamda
yıldız p
nal karakter
olmadığı
sürece
arkadaşlar
e
şimdi
çar
basamak değeri
digit olsun
yıldız p
is
eğer
yıldız p
ifadesini
tekrar etmemek
için böyle yazdım
digit
eşit
değilse
sıfır
ve
digit
eşit
değilse
bir
o zaman
geçerli
olmasın
biz de
exception
throw
edelim
arkadaşlar
exception
başlık
dosyamız
stud
except
dahil
ettim
runtime
error
göndereyim
throw
stud
runtime
error
invalid
binary
neyse böyle
olsun işte
şimdi
algoritmayı herkes biliyor değil mi
uval'e
yeni değer olarak
ikilik sayı sistemi olduğu için
uval
çarpı 2
artı
digit
eksi
sıfır
kullanılan karakter seti ne olursa olsun
rakam karakterlerinin
karakter setinde
ardışık
karakter kodları olması
garanti altında ama
harf karakterleri için böyle bir garanti yok
yani
26 tane harf karakteri var ya
bunlar
ardışık
kontikyüs olmak zorunda mı
a'dan sonra
b'den sonra
c c'den sonra
d gelmek zorunda mı
aski de öyle
unicode'un o kısmı da
yine aski olduğu için öyle
ama mesela eskiden kullanılıyordu
IBM'lerde hiç
kullanan var mı bilmiyorum
ismini de yanlış söylemek
istemiyorum
EBC
DIC
şöyle yazılıyordu
yanlış yazarsam
güzeltin
EBC
D
ÖC
mesela bu da bir karakter
kodlaması
EBC
DIC
diyorum ben
böyle okuyorum
fakat burada
harf karakterleri
ardışık değil
ama rakam karakterleri
yine ardışık
o genel kural karakter
kodlamasında
rakam karakterleri
ardışık olmak zorunda
ama harf karakterleri için
böyle bir garanti yok
dolayısıyla
örneğin siz
şöyle bir if deyimi yazsanız
diyelim ki
C bir karakter kodu
C
büyük eşit
A
ve aynı zamanda
C
küçük eşit
Z
bu durumda
büyük harf karakteri
derseniz
ASCII'de bu doğrudur
ama
EBC
DIC'de bu yanlış
çünkü
neden
A'dan Z'ye
kadar olan karakterler
karakter kodlamasında
ardışık
değil
hemen biz yine
buraya geri dönelim
buradaki algoritmayı
anlatmama gerek yok
değil mi
evet
10'luk sayı
sistemi olsaydı
çarpı
diyecektik
yine
digit
teksi sıfır olacaktır
peki
şimdi
P pointer'ını
bir arttıralım
art artı
şu noktada
örgülünü koyalım
artı artı
P
return
bu var
şimdi koda
bakın
arkadaşlar
hatta
şöyle yazalım
exception'ı
yakalayalım
exception gönderirse
Cout
underscore
B
çift tırnak yok
Mehmet Ali
Egeci
çarp ürünün bir
alt tipini
tanımlamak
mümkün mü
verdiğimiz örnek
için
yalnız sıfır
ve bir çarp tipi
olursa
daha güzel olabilir
ama anlayamamış
olabilirim
Mehmet Ali
çarp ürünün bir
alt tipini
tanımlamak
mümkün mü
derken
ne kastettiğinizi
anlamadım
ama burada
ben ne yapmak istedim
sıfır ya da bir
olmazsa
exception
throw ediyor
ama
dedinizde
belki
yani sizin
dedinizde yanlış
bir şey olmayabilir de
ben anlayamadım
peki
şimdi
bakalım
hayır hayır
böyle bir şey
olamaz
yani
sadece sıfır
ve bir
değerine sahip
bir tür
tabii ki
oluşturabilirsiniz
bir sınıf türü
ya da bir
enumeration
oluşturabilirsiniz
ama
fonksiyonun
parametre değişkeni
burada
çar olmak zorunda
başta da dedik ya
sadece
belirli türden
parametreler olabilir
tekrar
bakın
661'miş
hatta
şuna bakın
artı
evet
977'miş
ama
burada örneğin
bir ya da sıfır
olmayan bir karakter
olsaydı
örneğin
iki olsaydı
şurada
yani
16.
satırdaki
if
deyiminin
doğru kısmına
girecekti
ve
exception
row edecekti
az önce
verdiğim örneği de
gerçek haline
getirelim
bakın
fonksiyonun
geri dönüş
değeri olmak
zorunda da
değil
void
da olabilir
operator
shift
tırnak
underscore
arkadaşlar
pr
ya da print
artı hangi ismi
kullanırsanız
postchar
yıldız
takip edebiliyor muyuz
evet
arkadaşlar
şimdi
social
efendim
ne olsun
foksiyonun
bir de isim verelim
p
siya
şimdi burada
çok çok dikkatli
izlemenizi
isteyeceğim
çünkü tam
söylediğim
kritik değer
şimdi birinci
soruya cevap
verin önce
cooked mu
uncooked mu
pişmiş mi
pişmemiş mi
uncooked
bravo
peki bu fonksiyonu
nasıl çağıracağım
bakın bu fonksiyonu
şöyle çağıracağım
arkadaşlar
underscore
print
peki bu durumda
aslında fonksiyonumuz
bu tam sayıyı
yazdırmıyor
aslında bu fonksiyon
neyi yazdırıyor
kare
bu
adresteki yazıyı
yazdırıyor
espriyi
anladınız mı
yani
örneğin
şöyle
yazarsam
arkadaşlar
olur mu
23.56
artı
underscore
print
tabii
artık burada bu
bir yazı
yani nokta
içermesi
içermemesi
size kalmış
anlaşıldı
değil mi
evet
şöyle yazabilir miyim
alican
print
hayır
bu durumda
gördüğünüz gibi
bu doğrudan
bir identifier
olduğu için
olmaz
dolayısıyla
rakam karakteriyle
başlaması
gerekiyor
peki fonksiyonu
ismiyle
çağırsaydım
operatör
çift tırnak
underscore
print
ve fonksiyona
örneğin
şunu argüman olarak
gönderyecektim
ama işte bunu
çift tırnak
için de
almayı
ben yapmıyorum
derleyici
yapıyor
arkadaşlar
şimdi
şöyle yapalım
izleyin
bu arada
tam da
benim yine
mouse
pili bitmiş
size denk geliyor
hep
şimdi
buradan
literal
operatör
cpp
reference
açalım
evet
şimdi bakın
başta
söyledim
aslında
kullanılan terim
user
define
literal
ya da
operators
arkadaşlar
bakınız
aslında
yani uzun uzun
geçmek istemiyorum
ama
işte burası
diyor ki
standart
only the following
parameters
parameter lists
are allowed
on literal
operators
const char
yıldız olabilir
unsign
long
olabilir
double
char
olabilir
w
char
underscore
t
olabilir
ve
bunlar
olabilir
yani liste
ama bir de
template olması
durumu
var
o da
başka bir yerde
onun da
kuralları var
ama burada
değinmeyeceğim
şimdi ona
arkadaşlar
evet
peki
o zaman biz de
şimdi bu kadar
yeter
bunu burada
bırakalım
ve büyük
ona
geniş
şöyle
4-5
ters
sürecek
maalesef
bir konuya
başlayalım
en az
5 ters
iostream
kütüphanesi
arkadaşlar biz
baştan beri
aslında
iostream
kütüphanesini
kullanıyoruz
benim
iostream
kütüphanesi
dediğime
bakmayın
aslında
burada
iostream
derken
popüler olarak
kast edilen
iostream
aslında
arkadaşlar
doğrudan
bir
sınıfın da
ismi
fakat burada
iostream
kütüphanesi
derken
kast edilen
input
output
operations
giriş çıkış
işlemlerine
ilişkin
standart
kütüphanenin
hemen
hepsi
template olan
yani
generic kod olan
bileşenlerinden
bahsediyorum
arkadaşlar
giriş çıkış
burada ne anlamda
kullanılıyor
biliyoruz
ama ben
yine de
yani
burada
ne anlamda
kullandığımı
biraz daha
açıklamak için
şu klasik
resmi
göstermek istiyorum
bakın şimdi
burada
neyi kastediyorum
izleyin
arkadaşlar
C'de de
C++'da da
aslında
bir C
ya da
C++
programı
şöyle
temsil ediliyor
bu bizim
programımız
tabii
çalışma
çalıştığı haline
biz
proses
diyoruz
program
çalışırken
benim
tabirimle
dış dünyadan
programa
gelen
bizim
programımızın
kullanımına
sunulan
bir
byte
akışı
var
dış dünyadan
bu
byte'ların
nereden
geldiği
buradaki
soyutlamada
abstraction'da
bizi ilgilendirmiyor
bizi ilgilendiren şu
sanki
bir borudan
bu
byte'lar
bizim programımıza
doğru
akıyor
arkadaşlar
analojiyi
biraz daha
ilerletirsek
çok da fazla
değil
çünkü
bir analoji
kurduğunuzda
biraz
dozunu
açarsanız
bu sefer
gerçeği
yansıtmanın
dışına
çıkıyor
şimdi bu
borudan su
gelseydi
su
borunun
diğer ucundan
sürekli
akacaktı
ama oraya
biz bir musluk
musluk terimi
kave var mı
Farsça'da
belki de
Farsça'dan
gelmedi
musluk
o çeşif
oraya
bir musluk koyup
orayı
kapatıp
musluğu
açtığımızda
suyun
gelmesini
sağlayabiliriz
değil mi
buradaki
musluk
adeta
bir
bufferlama
mekanizması
oluşturuyor
işte
burada da
evet
byte'lar
gelirken
burunun
bir tarafında
da
bir
buffer var
aslında
öyle
düşünebilirsiniz
bu byte'lar
klavyeden
geliyor
olabilir
bir
dosyadan
file'dan
geliyor
olabilir
bir
network'den
geliyor
olabilir
bir
başka
programdan
geliyor
olabilir
arkadaşlar
bir
bellek
alanından
geliyor
olabilir
işte buna
input stream
diyoruz
burada
İngilizce'de
kullanılan
terim
stream
C'de
C++
maalesef
Türkçe'de
doğrudan
genel kabul
görmüş bir
karşılığı
yok
o yüzden
ben
kendi
seçtiğim terimi
kullanıyorum
ben buldum
anlamında
değil
bazıları
akış terimini
kullanıyor
bazıları
akım
terimini
kullanıyor
benim de
seçtiğim terim
akım
yani
input stream
giriş
akımı
aynı
şekilde
nasıl
buradan
dış dünyadan
borudan
byte'lar
programa doğru
geliyorsa
program çalışırken
bizim
programımızdan da
adeta böyle
bir borudan
geçerek
byte'lar
dış dünyaya
gidiyor
burada
ben
dış dünya
derken
programın
dışındaki
aygıtlardan
bahsediyorum
bu
doğrudan
konsol
olabilir
yani
kullanıcının
gördüğü
monitör
ekran
olabilir
bir dosya
yine
bir network
olabilir
bir başka
program
olabilir
yani
genel modelimiz
böyle
işte
oilstream
kütüphanesi
derken
oilstream
kütüphanesinin
bileşenleri
buradaki
bu süreçteki
bütün
operasyonlara
ilişkin
burada
bütün
operasyonlar
derken
maalesef
konu bir
hayli
geniş
arkadaşlar
şöyle söyleyeyim
karşılaşmış
olabilirsiniz
benim paylaştığım
kitap listesinde
de olabilir
oilstream
sen
lokal
diye bir
kitap var
kitabın
kendisi
yani
sadece
oilstream
bileşenlerini
anlatan
o da
modern
c++'dan
önce
yazılan
bir
kitap
kitabın
kendisi
ortalama
bir
programlama
dilini
anlatan
kitaptan
hatta
detaylı
başka bir
programlama
dilini
anlatan
kitaptan
neredeyse
daha kalın
şimdi
burada
giriş
çıkış
işlemleri
benim
Türkçe
kullandığım
tabirle
giriş
çıkış
işlemlerinde
neler
var
yani
şöyle
hadi
civarı
alt başlık
subtitle
oluşturmak
gerekse
bu
alt başlıklar
neler
olabilirdi
bir kere
giriş
ya da
çıkış
işleminin
İngilizcesiyle
formatted
ya da
unformatted
formatlı
ya da
formatsız
olması
söz konusu
yani
bir çıkış
işleminin
örneğin
formatlı
olması
başka
formatsız
olması
başka
ben
C
kursunda
formatlı
formatsız
derken
neyin
kastedildiğini
detaylı
açıklıyorum
ama
sizin de
bildiğinizi
varsayıyorum
ama
bilmeyenler için
ilk defa
duyanlar için
bu terimleri
kısa bir
açıklama
burada
kastedilen
şu
mesela
sizin
int
türden
bir değişkeniniz
var
int
x
eşittir
298.341
arkadaşlar
şimdi ben bunu
bir streame
versem
mesela bana
Cengiz Han
dese ki
Neco bunu
benim arkadaşlarım da
bana Neco
diyor
artık ben de alıştım
Neco bunu
bir streame
ver dese
benim şunu
sormam lazım
vereyim
vereyim de
formatlı mı
vereyim
formatsız mı
burada
kastedilen şu
formatlı
demek
onun
int'sı
onu
insanın
anlayacağı
bir forma
yani karakter
kodlarına
dönüştürmek
demek
mesela
kullanıcı
konsolda
298.341
yazısını
görecekse
aslında
bu
bellek de
size of int'in
4 olduğunu
düşünelim
bit'lık
alanda
tutulan
bir veri
olmasına
rağmen
ben bir takım
aritmetik işlemlerle
algoritma
koşturarak
bunu
bu karakter
kodlarına
dönüştürüyorum
yani bunun
bellekte
tutulduğu
haliyle
aktarıldığı
hal
farklı
yani
mesela
ASCII
karakter
kodlamasında
sıfırın
kodu
hex 30
decimal
o zaman
9 için
işte
8 için
bu karakter
kodlarına
dönüştüreceğim
ve bunun da
bir maliyeti var
ama ne yapalım
o Cem Yılmaz'ın
eski bir şey var
ben pek sevmem
Cem Yılmaz'ı
ama bazı
şakaları
esprileri
esniglendi
şaka terimi de yok
hep espri denirdi
şimdi ben de alışmaya
çalışıyorum
şaka terimle
şöyle bir
reklama vardı
bunu insan
yiyecek
böyle patates
patates
çipse
reklamında
burada da
bunu bir insan
okuyacak
insanın okuması
için
bize o
bite'lardaki
bitler
değil
bu karakter
kodları
lazım
işte bunu
dönüştürmenin de
bir maliyeti var
bu algoritmayı
hepiniz biliyorsunuz
örneğin bir tam sayıyı
bir yazıya dönüştürme
algoritması
fakat şimdi
bu formatlı
yani karakter
kodlarına
bir dönüşüm
söz konusuysa
insanın
anlayacağı
bir forma
bir yazıya
sokma
söz konusuysa
bu formatlı
giriş tarafında
da böyle
çıkış tarafında
ama şimdi
bir de şunu
düşünün
bir sıfır
bir
diyelim ki
tabi ben
gerçek değeri
doğrudan
binary olarak
yazabilecek
zeka seviyesine
sahip
değilim ama
bunun
x'in
bellek alanında
bu değere
karşılık gelen
byte'lar
olduğunu
düşünelim
tabi bu
doğru yazsam
bir de ne var
little end
değil mi
big end
little end
değil mi
big end
olması arasında
fark var
neyse efendim
konu o değil
arkadaşlar
şimdi
x'in değerini
veren
byte'lar
yani
bellekte
x'in
storage'ındaki
byte'lar
bunlar
bu byte'ların
kendisini
stream'e
veriyorsam
o zaman
bu
unformatted
output
bakın
c bilenler
ki zaten
ne demek
herkes biliyor
arkadaşlar
c bilenler
hatırlayacaklar
mesela c'de
tam sayılar
gerçek sayılar
yazılar
vesaire
için
formatlı çıkış
fonksiyonları
neler
içinde
printf
sözcüğü
geçen
öyle değil mi
içinde
printf
sözcüğü
geçen
ve
variadik parametre
bravo
kave
ve variadik
parametreye
sahip
fonksiyonlar
örneğin
printf
f
efendim
s
printf
sm
bunlar hep
arkadaşlar
variadik
fonksiyonlar
ve formatlı
çıkış
fonksiyonları
ama
mesela
formatsız
giriş
çıkış
fonksiyonlarına
örnek verelim
mesela
putcar
getcar
neden
e çünkü
örneğin biz
putcar
fonksiyonuna
arkadaşlar
çağrı yaptığımızda
ya da
getcar
fonksiyonuna
çağrı yaptığımızda
karakter kodunun
kendisine
alıyoruz
yani o byte'ın
değerini alıyoruz
ama daha iyi örnek
mesela dosyaya
yazma işlemi
yapan fonksiyonlardan
fprintf ile
fread'in
fwrite'ın
farkı
hatırlıyorsunuz
değil mi
arkadaşlar
fprintf
formatlı
çıkış fonksiyonu
ama
fwrite
doğrudan
bellekten
file'a
dosyaya
stream'e
transfer yapan
fonksiyon
fwrite'a
birinci parametresi
void pointer
bir adres
veriyorsunuz
bu adresten
başlayarak
arkadaşlar
diyelim ki
size of
int
byte'lık
bloklardan
efendim
bu da bir dizi
olsun
en tane
blok
bu handle ile
ilişkilendirilen
dosyaya yazılsın
aslında yapılan
doğrudan
bellekteki
byte'ların
dosyaya
aktarılması
işte
nasıl
c'de
fprintf
efendim
varken
aynı zamanda
fwrite isimli bir
fonksiyon var
biri
formatlı çıkış fonksiyonu
diğeri
formatssız
bizim standart
c++
kütüphanesinde de
yine
bu
çıkış işlemleri
ona
benzemeyen
şekilde
formatlı ya da
formatssız olabilir
ama şimdi
biz bu konuyu daha önce detaylı
işlememiş olsak da
herkes şunu hatırlıyor
olmalı
arkadaşlar
printf'lerin karşılığı
bizde ne
operatör
left shift fonksiyonları
değil mi
yani bizim
inserter dediğimiz
yani
bitwise
left shift
operatörünü
overload eden
fonksiyonlar
formatlı
çıkış fonksiyonları
ki
onlara da
ister istemez
değineceğiz
yani siz örneğin
int türden
bir değişkenin
değerini
bir yazı olarak
yazdırmak için
şöyle yazıyorsunuz
değil mi
see out
efendim
int
evolve
başmasın
aslında biz burada
hepimizin daha önceden de
bildiği gibi
operatör left shift
fonksiyonunu
çağırıyoruz
bu burada
çağırılan sınıfın
üye fonksiyonu
ve bu fonksiyona
arkadaşlar
argüman olarak
şunu da silelim
evet bu fonksiyona
argüman olarak
evalü
gönderiyoruz
ama bazı durumlarda da
çağırdığımız fonksiyon
global operatör fonksiyonu
ama hep
ismi
operatör left shift
mesela operatör left shift
see out
efendim
kv
demek ki bizde
formatlı çıkış fonksiyonları
aslında operatör
left shift fonksiyonları
formatlı giriş fonksiyonları da
operatör
right shift fonksiyonları
böyle genel bir konvensiyon var
genel konvensiyonun
olmasının
nedeni
daha önce biraz
konuşmuştuk
custom type'lar içinde
aynı
interfejsi
kullanabilmek
arkadaşlar
şimdi burada
çok sayıda sınıf var
bu sınıfların
farklı farklı
işlevleri var
eğer burayı
tam olma
standarttaki
ayrıntılarıyla
görmek istesek
50 saat kafadan
koymak gerekiyor
o yüzden
ben
en önemli
en kritik
yerlerden
başlayarak
detaya ineceğim
bazı
detaylar
doğrudan
bu konuda
kodu yazmıyorsanız
sizin için
önemli olmayabilir
ama bazı detaylar
çok çok
önemli
şimdi burada
bizim kütüphanemiz
sinin standart
kütüphanesi
gibi değil
biliyoruz bunu
biliyoruz
ama
burada
object oriented
bir yandan
diğer taraftan da
jenerik
paradigmasal
öğeler
kullanılıyor
mesela
object oriented
derken
neyi
kastediyorum
arkadaşlar
streamleri
nesnelerle
temsil ediyoruz
mesela
standart
çıkış akımını
temsil eden
standart
çıkış akımını
kontrol eden
bir global
sınıf
nesnesi var
standart
giriş akımını
temsil eden
bir
global
sınıf
nesnesi var
bu
sınıfların
üye
fonksiyonları
var
bazı
fonksiyonlarda
global
fonksiyonlar
dolayısıyla
streamler
birer
object olarak
temsil ediliyor
nesne yönelimli
tarafta
yani
burada
object orientation
var mı
belirli
seviyede var
runtime
polimorfizmi
çok az
bir yerde
var
yok
denecek
kadar az
ama
bu
nesne yönelimli
tarafta
mesela neler
var
sınıflar
az önce
söylediğim gibi
örneğin streamler
sınıflarla
temsil ediliyor
ama
aynı zamanda
kalıtım var
inheritance
burada bir
kalıtım
yerarşisi var
giriş çıkış
sınıflarında
kompozisyon var
bazı yerlerde
bufferların
kullanılması
tarafında
ve
ayrıca
kalıtım var
bir de
çoklu
kalıtım var
multiple
inheritance
ve
virtual
inheritance
da var
yani
nesne
yönelimli
programlama
tarafında
sınıflar
sınıfların
üye
fonksiyonları
inheritance
multiple
virtual
inheritance
bütün bu
oyalar
gerçekten
sınıfta
var ve
kompozisyon
da var
yine
pointer
yoluyla
olsa da
arkadaşlar
jenerik
tarafta
ise
arkadaki
kodların
hepsi
neredeyse
istisna
çok az
yok
denecek
kadar az
hepsi
birer
template
yani örneğin
bizim
şimdiye kadar
o stream
olarak
kullandığımız
sınıf
aslında
bir sınıf
şablonunun
yani jenerik
bir sınıfın
bir
specializationı
aslında bir
studio stream
yazmakla
tıpkı
string sınıfında
olduğu gibi
arkadaşlar
stud
basic
o stream'in
arkadaşlar
char virgül
bakın
iki tane
tıpkı parametresi var
char virgül
stud
chart rates'in
char
açılımını
kullanıyoruz
aslında
bizim
kullandığımız
sınıf
böyle bir
ama
buna
türeş
ismi
verilmiş
type
alias
verilmiş
verdiğimiz
türeş
ismi
o stream
arkadaşlar
şimdi
şöyle
biraz
müsaade ederseniz
büyük bir
yararşi var
ki burada
buffer
sınıfları da
yok
şimdi
burayı
başlangıçta
detaylı öğrenmeniz
gerekmiyor
ilk defa
tanışanlar için
söylüyorum
arkadaşlar
şimdi bu
sınıf
yararşilerinde
genelde şöyle bir
özellik var
değil mi
ortak
bütün sınıflarda
olacak
özellikler
hep yukarıya
kaydırılıyor
yani
bütün stream
sınıfları
buradaki
sınıf
yararşisinde
ama
stream
sınıflarının
arkadaşlar
ortak
özellikleri
hep
havan
sınıfta
base
klas
ya da
klaslarda
yararşi hakkında
bilmeniz
gereken
aslında ilk şey
şu
şimdi
burada
streamler söz
konusu olduğu
zaman
iki tane
önemli
birleşen var
jenerik hale
getirmek için
biri
stringde
kullanılacak
karakterin
türü
ki
biz
kursumuzun
sonuna
kadar
bütün bu
stream
sınıflarında
streamde
kullanılacak
karakter
türü
olarak
yani
bu
template
olanların
birinci
template
parametresine
karşılık
gelen
template
argümanı
olarak
hep
char
türünü
kullanacağız
ama
tabi ki
char olmak
zorunda
değil
örneğin
w char
underscore
t ya da
başka bir
karakter
türü
olabilir
ikinci
template
parametresi
ise
hani o
default
char
traits'in
birinci
template
parametresine
karşılık
gelen
template
argümanı
açılımı
olan
ikinci
template
parametresi
ise
aslında
neyi
belirliyor
kabaca
söylemek
gerekirse
bu karakterler
arasındaki
işlemlerin
nasıl yapılacağını
belirliyor
böylece
bunlar
birbirinden
izole edilmiş
yani
bir
akımdaki
streamdeki
karakter
türü var
örneğin
yazının
bir karakteri
gibi
bir de
bu karakterlerin
arasında
karakterlerle
ilgili
bazı işlemlerin
nasıl yapılacağını
belirleyen
bir
trait
template
parametresi
var
şimdi
hiyerarşide
en yukarıdaki
sınıfın
ismi
iOS
Base
burayı
biraz daha
dikkatli izlemeniz
gerekiyor ama
ara vaktim de
gelmiş
birkaç
cümle daha
söyleyeyim
iOS
Base
sınıfı
bir sınıf
şabrını
değil
yani
sadece
hiyerarşideki
İngilizcesiyle
en tepedeki
taban sınıf
ne değil
arkadaşlar
bir template
değil
çünkü bu sınıfta
bakın
hangi özellikler
tutuluyor
streamin
input mu
output mu
olduğundan
bağımsız
streamdeki
hayır hayır
bu
virtual
değil
doğrudan
emiran
şöyle söyleyelim
streamin
input stream
ya da output
stream olmasından
bağımsız
streamdeki
karakter
türünden de
bağımsız
interface
iOS
Base'de
Base'den
kalıtım
yoluyla elde edilen
Basic
iOS
sınıfı
artık bir
sınıf
şablonu
jenerik bir
sınıf
az önce
söylediğim gibi
iki tane
template
parametresi var
Basic
iOS'da da
yine
ama bu kez
akımdaki
karakter
türüne
ve
trade'e
bağlı
olan
fakat
giriş
ya da
çıkış
akımı
olmasından
bağımsız
interface'de
nereye
kaydırılmış
Basic
iOS'a
kaydırılmış
arkadaşlar
işte ondan
sonra
Basic
o stream
çıkış
akımlarının
taban
sınıfı
işte
giriş
çıkış
fonksiyonları
burada
artık
mesela
operator
left
shift
fonksiyonları
Basic
O
streaming
fonksiyonları
Basic
i
stream
ise
operator
right
chip
fonksiyonlarını
veren
yani
giriş
input
streamlerle
ilgili
sınıf
arkadaşlar
bir şey
dikkatinizi
çekiyor
mu
gerek
Basic
o
stream
gerek
basic
i
stream
basic
ios
sınıfından
kalıtım
yoluyla
elde edilmiş
kalıtımın
ne olduğunu
biliyorsunuz
yani
bu durumda
bunlar
tavan sınıfının
interfezine
public
kalıtım olduğu
için
kendilerine
katmış
durumdalar
bizim
şimdiye kadar
hiç doğrudan
kullanmadığımız
bundan sonra da
kendisini doğrudan
kullanmayacağımız
Basic
ios
stream
sınıfı
Multiple
inheritance
da
Basic
o
stream
ve
basic
i
stream
den
elde edilmiş
işte
Multiple
inheritance
bulunduğu
yer
burası
eğer
burada
yukarıdaki
taban
sınıflar
Virtual
Inheritance
ile
arkadaşlar
bravo
tam da oraya
geldik
emiranda
Virtual
Inheritance
kastetmiş
özür dilerim
ben yanlış
anlamışım
rasul da
aynı şeyi
söylüyor
diamond
formasyonu
oluşmasın
diye
dreadful
diamond
of
derivation
buradaki
kalıtımlar
rasul
Virtual
Inheritance
böylece
basic
ios
stream
ve ondan
kalıtım
yoluyla elde edilen
sınıflarda
basic
ios
ve
base
sınıfı
nesnelerinden
ikişer tane
mi olacak
birer tane
cevap
olacak
çünkü
bakınız
buradaki
kalıtımlar
bu konuyu
hatırlıyoruz
değil mi
Virtual
Inheritance
neler
görmüşüz
çok ders olmuş
arkadaşlar
kaç saate
gelmişiz
hatırlıyoruz
değil mi
Virtual
Inheritance
peki
şimdi şöyle
yapalım
saat 21.05
diyelim
bir ara verelim
21.25
de devam
edelim
değerli
arkadaşlar
Arkadaşlar
şu sınıf
hiyerarşisini
ve
nesne
önemini
programlamayla
ilgisini
anlatıyordum
buradaki
sınıflar
bazı sınıflar
giriş çıkış
sınıfları
onu söyledik
kalıtım
hiyerarşisi
var dedik
işte
burada
kalıtım yolu
elde edilen
sınıflar
giriş ya da
çıkış işlemlerinin
hangi kaynağı
yapıldığıyla
ilgili
mesela
Basic
Ostream
sınıfı
arkadaşlar
biliyorsunuz
Havan
çıkış
sınıflarının
Havan
sınıfı
diğer çıkış
sınıflarına
bir
interfaz
veriyor
örneğin
StudSea
Basic
Ostream
sınıfı
türünden
bir nesne
fakat
eğer
çıkış
belleğe
yapılacaksa
İngilizce
In
Memory
Input
Output
Operations
deniyor
burada
yine
Ostream
ve
Istream
sınıflarından
şu
mouse'umuzu
açalım
kalıtım
yoluyla
elde edilen
arkadaşlar
neler var
Basic
Ostream
Stream
Basic
Istream
Stream
ve
Basic
String
Stream
sınıfı
var
yani
örneğin
çıkış
işlemini
belleğe
yapacaksak
Basic
Ostream
Stream
sınıfını
ki
o da bir
Basic
Ostream
çünkü
public
kalıtımıyla
Basic
Ostream
sınıfından
elde ediliyor
giriş işlemini
bellekten
yapacaksak
Basic
Istream
Stream
ama
hem okuma
hem yazma
işlemlerini
yapacaksak
yani
hem
Ostream'in
hem de
Istream'in
interfezini
edinmek
istiyorsak
bellek üstünde
hem okuma
hem yazma
işlemi
yapacaksak
Basic
String
Stream
sınıfını
kullanıyoruz
o da gördüğünüz
gibi
Basic
Iostream
sınıfından
kalıtım yoluyla
elde ediliyor
giriş çıkış işlemlerinin
dosyalar
üstünde yapılması
için de
bazı derslerde
biraz ezbere de
olsa
kullanmıştık
Basic
Off
Stream
Basic
If
Stream
ve
Basic
F
Stream
sınıfları var
arkadaşlar
burada
doğrudan
gösterilmeyen
bir de
aslında
işlemlerin
hemen hepsini
arka planda
yürüten
buffer
sınıflarımız
var
işte burada
daha iyi
görülüyor
biraz daha
farklı bu
Yostis'in
kitabından
alınan
resim
gördüğümüz gibi
burada
Basic
Iostream
ve Basic
Ostream'in
Virtual
Inheritance'da
Basic
Iostan
kalıtım
yoluyla
elde edildiğini
görüyorsunuz
arkadaşlar
ve
az önceki
resimde
gösterilmeyen
işte o
bufferlama kısmı
ki
perde gerisindeki
gerçek kahraman
bu
buffer sınıfları
Basic
Stream
Buff
ve ondan
kalıtım yoluyla
elde edilen
Basic
String
Buff
sınıfları
var
aslında
bu sınıflar
bu sınıflara
pointer tutarak
bufferlama
işlemlerini
bu sınıf
türünden
nesnelerle
gerçekleştiriyorlar
diyebiliriz
arkadaşlar
şimdi
burada
bir iki
noktayı
belki
çok sık
tekrar ediyorum
ama
çok önemli
Public
Inheritance'ın
canlı bir örneği
neden
mesela bu
hiyerarşideki
en aşağıdaki
sınıflardan
biri de
olsa
örneğin
Basic
Iostring
Stream
sınıfı
o
IOS
Base'deki
interfeise
sahip
Basic
IOS'daki
interfeise
sahip
Basic
Iostring'deki
interfeise
sahip
bufferlama
tam olarak
ne demek
arkadaşlar
buffer demek
bir bellek
alanı
demek
yani
burada
bufferın
birinci
anlamı
bir bellek
alanı
yani
karakterler
aslında
bizim programımıza
geliyor
ama
onların
birerli bir kısmı
bir bellek
alanında
tutuluyor
ve o bellek
alanından
kontrollü
olarak
o karakterler
alınıyor
böyle
düşünebilirsiniz
evet
yani
burada
bir
soyutlama
abstraction
söz konusu
ama
temel
birinci
anlamıyla
burada
bufferdan
kast edilen
bir bellek
alanı
o bellek
alanında
işte bu
karakter
white
değerleri
var
biz onları
arkadaşlar
okuma
tarafında
o karakterleri
bufferdan
alıyoruz
yazma
tarafında
da
önce
buffera
yazılıyor
bazı
eventler
gerçekleştiği
zaman
bufferdan
device'a
aktarılıyor
onları
göreceğiz
Allah'ın izniyle
arkadaşlar
birden fazla
başlık dosyası
var
işte buradaki
resimde de
hangi sınıfların
hangi başlık
dosyasında
olduğu
hangi başlık
dosyasının
hangi header
file'ın
file'ları
include
ettiği
gösteriliyor
hangi sınıfların
jenerik
olduğu
gösteriliyor
bunlara
bu sınıfları
anlattığım zaman
geleceğim
ama şimdi
asıl ben çok
kritik
birkaç noktaya
değinmek istiyorum
bundan sonra
ayrıntılara
girmeden
arkadaşlar
baka şimdi
burası bence
en önemli
kısım
nesne yönelimli
programlamada
nesneler var
değil mi
yani
objektler
var
bir de bu
objektlerin
ilişkin olduğu
class'lar var
mesela
hep
şimdiye kadar
örneklerde
kolay anlaşılsın
diye kullandığım
sınıf vardı
en azından
sözel verdiğim
örneklerde
oyun programındaki
fighter
fighter sınıfı
arkadaşlar
türünden
bir nesne
oyun programındaki
savaşçıyı
temsil ediyordu
savaşçının
bir savaşma gücü var
belki
ismi var
yaşı var
silahları var
arkadaşlar
ve
savaşçı
bazı eylemleri
yürütebiliyor
şimdi bakınız
bu
eylem kısmına
savaşçının
yapabildiği
operasyonlara
behavior
diyelim
davranış
fakat bir de
savaşçının
state'i var
state terimi
bence çok
önemli bir
terim
Türkçe
birinci
karşılığı
durum
arkadaşlar
örneğin
eğer
savaşçının
yaşı
İngilizcesi
eğici
onun
state'inin
bir parçasıysa
örneğin
bir savaşçı
benim gibi
yaşlı olurken
başka bir
savaşçı
ayağın gibi
çok genç
bir arkadaş
olabilir
belki
savaşçının
savaşma
gücü
yaşıyla da
ilgili
olabilir
ve
bazı
operasyonlar
nesnelerin
state'ini
değiştiriyor
değil mi
mesela
savaşçı
yaşlanıyor
silah ediniyor
yani
davranışı
belirleyen
genel olarak
nesnenin
state'i
state
değişince
hepsi
olmasa da
bazı
davranışlar
değişiyor
işte
bakın
stream
sınıflarının da
birden
bir genel
state'i var
yani
örneğin
iki stream
nesnesi
aynı
state'de
olabilir
ya da
farklı
state'de
olabilir
fakat
stream
sınıfları
söz konusu
olduğunda
biz
stream
nesnelerinin
bu durum
bilgilerini
state bilgilerini
birbirinden
ayrı
belki
alt başlıklar
halinde
öğrenmeliyiz
mesela
bir stream
nesnesinin
state'i derken
neler
kastediliyor
şimdi
burada
object oriented
programming'in
çok tipik
bence bir örneği
arkadaşlar
state'in
en önemli
bileşenlerinden
biri
İngilizcesiyle
ki biz oradan
başlayacağız
formatting state
yani
formatlama
durumu
bu şu demek
mesela
sea out
bir stream
nesnesi
değil mi
global
ve değişken
aslında
biz
başlık dosyasını
inkludet ettiğimizde
bir sınıf
nesnesinin
extern
bildirimine
ediniyoruz
dolayısıyla
sea out
nesnesinin
bir state'i var
bu state'in
en önemli
bileşenlerinden
biri
az önce
söylediğim gibi
format state
ya da
formatting state
arkadaşlar
ne demek
formatlama
state'i
durumu
mesela
siz
sea out
nesnesini
kullanarak
bir tam sayıyı
formatlı olarak
standart
output'a
yazdıracaksınız
peki tam sayıyı
yazdırırken
hangi sayı
sisteminde
yazdıracaksınız
10'luk mu
8'lik mi
2'lik mi
hexadecimal sayı
sisteminde mi
yazarken
önek
kullanılacak mı
kullanılmayacak mı
mesela
hex bir değeri
16'luk sayı
sistemindeki bir değeri
ab
f
biçiminde mi
yazacak
yoksa
0x
ab
d
f
biçiminde mi
yazacak
eğer
hexadecimal
basamaklar
bunları
büyük harfle mi
yazacak
küçük harfle mi
önek
arkadaşlar
tabi tabi
bakın
bu ol
alfayı
görmüştük
bu ona bir
örnek mi
diyor
kesinlikle
bir örnek
birazdan
zaten detaya
gireceğiz
alham
bravo
diyorum
çünkü
mesela
sayı sistemi
önekini
yazarken
x küçük mü
yazılsın
büyük mü
efendim
bir gerçek
sayı yazarken
nokta
olsun mu
mesela gerçek
sayının
ondalık kısmı
sıfırsa
3 mü
yazsın
3.0
mı
yazsın
benim
C kursumda
da anlattığım
çok sayıda
formatlama
özelliği
var
ve bu
formatlama
özellikleri
o stream
nesnelerinin
örneğin
state'i
arkadaşlar
bu şu
demek
mesela
ben
bir
o stream
nesnesine
kullanırken
bu bir dosya
ya yazacak
o stream
nesnesi
olabilir
benle
yazacak
olabilir
ya da
standart
output'a
yazacak
C out
nesnesi
olabilir
bu state'i
İngilizcesiyle
get
vs.
set
edebiliyorum
mesela
az önce
Ali Hanım
verdiği örnek
boolean
değerleri
true
false
olarak mı
yazsın
bu
format state'inin
bir bileşeni
eğer
format state'i
boolean
değerleri
olarak
yazacak
şekilde ise
siz o
format state'ini
değiştirmediğiniz
sürece
o hep
olarak
yazacak
ama
true
false
olarak
yazacak
durumdaysa
boolean
değerleri
hep
true
false
olarak
yazacak
bu
şu
demek
formatlı
çıkış
fonksiyonları
yani
operatör
left
shift
fonksiyonları
standart
kütüphanenin
bize
verdiği
örneğin
inti
yazdıracak
olan
double
yazdıracak
olan
örnek
veriyorum
yazdırma
işleminden
önce
format
state'e
bakıyor
o format
state'i
ne ise
ona göre
yazıyor
burayı
anlamanız
çok önemli
arkadaşlar
giriş tarafında
da öyle
o yüzden
formatlı
giriş
çıkış
işlemleri
söz konusu
olduğunda
bizim
neyi
çok iyi
anlamamız
gerekiyor
bu
format
state'in
ne olduğunu
ve
nasıl
set edildiğini
get edildiğini
öğrenmemiz
gerekiyor
arkadaşlar
mesela
iki tane
stream
nesnesi
aynı
buffer'ı
kullanıyor
olabilir
ama
bunların
format
state'i
farklı
olabilir
örnek
olarak
veriyorum
arkadaşlar
ben
örneğin
tam
sayıları
eksadesimal
sayı
sisteminde
önek
kullanarak
harf
karakterleri
büyük harf
yazılacak
şekilde
yazdıracak
bir format
state'ine
getirebilirim
bir
o stream
nesnesini
işte
ilk olarak
bizde
bunun
nasıl
yapıldığını
göreceğiz
arkadaşlar
şimdi burası
hem
başlangıçta
biraz karmaşık
hem
biraz
öğrenme
yükü
getiriyor
hem de
biraz
otoseviyede
bakarsak
bitsel işlemler
konusunda da
biraz
programcının
temel düzeyde
bilgi sahibi
olmasını
gerektiriyor
o yüzden
bazı
arkadaşlarım
sıkılabilir
bazı
arkadaşlarım
bitsel işlemler
konusunda
deneyimli
değilse
bazı
küçük
operasyonları
fonksiyonları
örneğin
anlamayabilir
şimdi o zaman
hemen girelim
Alihan Bey'in
dediği yerden
başlayalım
arkadaşlar
bazı
formatlama
özellikleri
ya var
ya yok
şeklinde
yani
boolean
değerler
ama her
formatlama
özelliği
böyle değil
mesela
az önceki
verdiği
örneklerde
sunların
boolean
formatlama
niteliği
olduğu
hemen
anlaşılıyor
değil mi
çünkü iki seçenek
var
ya 0
ya
true
false
öyle değil mi
evet
ben
bu
şekildeki
formatlama
özelliklerine
on
off
flex
diyorum
yani
ya on
durumunda
ya off
ya true
durumunda
ya false
peki
Necati ben bir şey
anlamadım
burayı çok dikkatli
izleyelim
şimdi
mesela
benim intürden
bir değişkenim var
değeri bu
ve ben
see out
nesnesini
yani
basic
o stream
nesnesini
kullanarak
x'i
formatlı bir şekilde
yazdırıyorum
peki
nereden
biliyor bu
10'luk sayı
sisteminde
yazacağını
efendim
mesela niye
16'lık sayı
sisteminde
yazmıyordu
10'luk sayı
sisteminde
yazıyor
ya da
boolean bir değeri
yazdırırken
örneğin
10 büyüktür
neden
0-1 olarak
yazıyor
çünkü
formatlama
niteliklerinin
hemen
hepsinin
bir default
değeri var
yani
başlangıçta
siz
diyelim ki
bir
o stream
nesnesi
oluşturduğunuz
zaman
onun
format
stateini
değiştirmezseniz
formatlama
özellikleri
standartın
belirlediği
belli
değerlerde
eğer onlar
size uygunsa
format
state'i
değiştirmeniz
gerekmiyor
ama onlar
size uygun
değilse
format
state'i
değiştirmeniz
gerekiyor
size uygun
şekilde
yazdırma
işlemini
okuma tarafında
da
okuma işlemini
yapabilsin
diye
burayı
anladık
mı
arkadaşlar
peki bu
nasıl
yapılıyor
bakın
önce
on off
bayraklarına
örnekler
verelim
en tipik
örnekler
şunlar
hepsini
yazmayacağım
ama
önemli bir
kısmını
yazacağım
sonra bu
işlemlerin
nasıl
yapıldığını
anlatacağım
şu anda
anlattıklarım
sadece
on off
olanlar
yani
boolean
olanlar
arkadaşlar
deminki
örnekten
başlayalım
boole değerlerin
yazılması
arkadaşlar
yani
ya 0-1
ya
true-false
bu arada bir soru
şimdi
niye
true-false
mesela bu
Almanca olsaydı
true anlamında
var
efendim
yanlış anlamında
falsch
yazdırabilir miydi
evet
o da
lokalizasyonla ilgili
o da aslında
yine
giriş çıkış
işlemlerinin
Airstream
kütüphanesiyle
alakalı
burada
richtig değil de
kullanılan
Almanca'daki
terim
var
bu kullanılıyor
yani
boolean anlamında
sizin dediğiniz şüphesiz
doğru
ama
burada
hani bizim
programlama tarafında
boolean da
richtig değil de
var
kullanılıyor
yani
normal dildeki
anlamından
bahsetmiyorum
yani
lokalizasyon özelliği de
böyle
yani örneğin
Almanca lokalini
alırsam
Almanca lokalinde
boolean değeri
yazarken
richtig yazmayacak
falsch yazacak
Muhammed
Yusuf
anlaşıldı mı
evet
peki
şimdi
o zaman
kaldığımız yere
geri dönelim
boolean değerlerin
nasıl yazıldığı
ama
sadece bu
değil
mesela
hexadecimal
sayı
sisteminde
yazarken
arkadaşlar
buraya dikkat
alplerin
büyük ya da
küçük yazılacağı
ya da
0x'teki
x'in küçük
ya da büyük
yazılacağı
bunların
bazı
özellikle
karşılıkları da var
normal
programlama tarafında
mesela buna
genel olarak
bu formatlama
özelliğine
uppercase
deniyor
arkadaşlar
yani
hexadecimalde
uppercase
olup olmayacağı
özelliği
başka
buraya dikkat
bir başka
formatlama
özelliği
örneğin
noktanın
yazılıp
yazılmayacağı
gerçek sayılarda
ona
show point
deniyor
arkadaşlar
sekizlik
okkal
ya da
16'lık
sayı
sisteminde
önekin
yazılıp
yazılmayacağı
bu formatlama
özelliğine
show base
deniyor
bunlar
kullanılan
bazı
programlama
dillerinde de
aynı terimler
kullanılıyor
o zaman
bool değerlerin
yazılması
hexadecimal
sayı sisteminde
yazılım yaparken
uppercase
olup olmayacağı
noktanın
gösterilip
gösterilmeyeceği
sayı sistemi
tabanının
base'in
yazılıp
yazılmayacağı
bunlar hep
arkadaşlar ne
boolean
formatlama
özellikleri
bir tane daha
artı
pozitif
bir tam sayının
yazılması
durumunda
artının
yazılıp
yazılmayacağı
yani örneğin
45 mi
yazılsın
artı
45 mi
yazılsın
buna da
nedendiğini
biliyor musunuz
buna da
show
pozitif
deniyor
demek ki biz
hemen daha
burada
formatlama
özelliklerinden
boolean
olan birkaç
tanesini
saydık
ama bunlarla
sınırlı değil
bakın ben
burada
tabi hepsini
anlatacağım
bunları o yüzden
biraz sıkılacaksınız
diyorum size
arkadaşlar
formatlama
özelliklerinde
boolean
olanları
en azından
burada
göstereyim
bakın
uppercase
ya büyük harfi
yazacak
ya yazmayacak
unit buff
bu da
yine
boolean
ya unit buffering
yapacak
anlatacağım
unit bufferingin
ne olduğunu
ya unit buffering
olmayacak
bakın bunlara
dikkat ederseniz
hep iki seçenek
var
skip
whitespace
w s diye
yazılıyor
ya
bazı okuma işlemlerinde
whitespace
karakterleri
atlayacak
ingilizcedeki
skip
fiilini
biliyorsunuz
ya
atmamayacak
artı karakterini
ya gösterecek
ya göstermeyecek
noktayı
ondalık
yazımda
ya gösterecek
yazacak
ya yazmayacak
sayı sistemini
ya gösterecek
ya göstermeyecek
takip edebiliyor musunuz
evet
boolean değerleri
ya true
ya false
olarak
yazacak
true false
olarak
ya da
0-1
olarak
yazacak
işte bu grup
on-off bayrağı
ama arkadaşlar
bütün formatlama özellikleri
on-off bayrağı
olamaz
mesela sayı sistemi
3 tane sayı sisteminde
yazma imkanı var
10'luk
8'lik
ve
16'lık
dolayısıyla
2 tane değer yok ki
on-off bayrağı olsun
bunların nasıl
set edildiğini
get edildiğini
ayrıca öğreneceğiz
arkadaşlar
efendim
sola dayalı mı
sağa dayalı mı
internal olarak mı
yazılsın
bu da yine
ne değil
on-off bayrağı değil
işte bunların hepsini
öğreneceğiz
ama merak etmeyin
son derece
başlangıçta karmaşık gibi
görünse de
kolay
arkadaşlar
şimdi o zaman
başlıyoruz
en tepedeki
tamam sınıfta
arkadaşlar
pmt flex
isimli
bitsel operasyonlara
uygun olması
gereken
fakat
gerçekte
hangi tür
olacağı
compiler'a
derleyiciye
bırakılan
format state'i
belirlemek için
kullanılan bir tür
var
yani bu tür
aslında
hangi sınıfın
bir nested type'ı
en tepedeki
ion space
vardı ya
arkadaşlar
bunun
nested type'ı
fmt flex
bir
type alias
arkadaşlar
derleyicilerde
çoğunlukla
fmt flex
türü
işaretli
int türünün
eş ismi
ama bizim
yapacağımız
işlemler açısından
bunun hangi
türü olduğu
bizi doğrudan
ilgilendirmiyor
takip edebiliyor
muyuz
evet
demek ki
bitsel işlemlere
uygun
fmt flex
türünden
türü var
ve
dikkat
formatlama
state'inin
hepsi
olmasa da
önemli bir kısmı
aslında
fmt flex
türünden
bir değişkenin
bitlerinde
tutuluyor
kafanızda
şöyle canlandırın
mesela
o stream'in
bir veri elemanı
var
bir data
member'ı
var
o fmt flex
türünden
onun da
bitleri var
sadece beni
izleyin
işte
bu bitlerin
crew ya da
false olması
yani sıfır
ya da bir
olması
formatlama
state'inin
ne olduğunu
belirliyor
bu durumda
on-off
bayrakları
doğrudan
birer bit
yani mesela
belki de bu bit
tamamen
derleyiciye
bağlı
boolean değerler
true
false
olarak mı
yazılsın
sıfır
bir
olarak mı
yazılsın
o bilgiyi
tutuyor
belki de bu bit
arkadaşlar
uppercase
olsun mu
olmasın
mı
onu tutuyor
register mantığı
gibi
bravo
belki de bu bit
ayağın
birazdan göstereceğim
efendim
sayı sistemi
tabanı
gösterilsin mi
gösterilmesin mi
o değeri
tutuyor
şimdi
çok dikkatli
izleyin
arkadaşlar
biz bitleri
set etmek için
neden bitsel
işlemleri
biraz bilmeniz
gerekiyor
dediğimi
şimdi anlayacaksınız
aslında ne
yapıyoruz
ya son derece
basit
mesela biz
bu biti
arkadaşlar
ne olduğunu
bilmesek
bu biti
birlemek
istesek
şöyle bir
maskeyle
bit
maskle
veya
bitsel
veya işlemine
tabi tutmamız
gerekir
değil mi
kavi
bu biti
sıfırlamamız
gerekse de
o zaman da
şöyle bir
maskeyle
bunu
ne yapmamız
gerekir
v işlemine
bitwise
end işlemine
sokmamız
gerekir
şimdi
herkes
çok dikkatli
izliyor
işte bakın
buradaki
maskelere
karşılık
gelen
en tepedeki
taban sınıfın
constexpr
fmt
flex
türünden
veri elemanları
var
yani bunlar
isimlendirilmiş
sabitler
türleri
fmt
flex
işte o
meşhur
ios
base'in
arkadaşlar
bakın tam
namespace
içinde yazıyor
ios
base'in
aslında
fmt
flex
türünden
örneğin
bull alfa
aslında
bitsel bir
maskeden
başka bir şey
değil
arkadaşlar
bakın
ben
bull alfa
sabitinin
bitlerini
yazdırsam
kb
ne göreceğim
kim tahmin ediyor
bir biti bir
diğer bitleri sıfır
isterseniz deneyelim
bakın bitset başlık dosyasını dahil edeyim
ve
bitset'in
32 açılımı
türünden
bir
temporary object
oluşturayım
onu
ios
base'in
bull alfası ile
arkadaşlar
set edeyim
ve bunu da
standart
output'a
yazdırayım
yani bu
maskelerin ne olduğunu
anlamanız için
söylüyorum
kb
alian ve diğer
arkadaşlarım ne
yazacak
muhakkak ki
hangi bitinin
bir olduğu
beni ilgilendirmiyor
ki ben arka
planda ne oluyor
onu göstermek istiyorum
mesela benim denleyicimin
implementasyonunda
bu bit
bull alfabetiymiş
bu şu demek
bu bit birken
arkadaşlar
0 1 olarak
yazıyor
bu bit
özür dilerim
bu bit birken
true false olarak
yazıyor
bu bit sıfırken
o zaman
0 1 olarak
yazıyor
buraya kadar
takip edebildik mi
tamam
şimdi peki
bunu nasıl
get ve set edeceğim
ya son derece
basit
şimdi
aslında
bir fonksiyon var
bu fonksiyonun ismi
bu bir member
function
tepedeki taban sınıfı
bu member
function
ismi
set f
yani örneğin
siz
siyah altın
set f
fonksiyonunu
çağırırsanız
buradaki
pek parametreli
set f
fonksiyonu
burada
tabi set f'nin
ben türkçe
okuyorum
set f diye
okuyun
ya da set formatın
f'si aslında
sizden
sadece
maskeyi istiyor
yani örneğin
bul alfa bitini
gru hale getirmek için
benim ne yapmam
gerekiyor
bul alfa bitini
set etmem
gerekiyor
onun için
set f'ye
neyi geçiyorum
o maskeyi
geçiyorum
yani
ios space'in
bul alfa
sabitini
geçiyorum
peki
bunun kodu
aslında nasıl
ya son derece
basit
bunun kodu
aslında
bu maskeyle
sınıfın
veri elemanını
bitsel
veya işlemine
sokuyor
burayı anladık mı
ya necati
şimdi böyle bir çağrı
yaptığımızda
böyle bir çağrı
artık
true false olarak
yazmaya mı
geçecek
kesinlikle
bakınız
izleyin
see out
boolean değer
10 büyüktür
default durumda
unset durumunda
buraya biraz ayrıntılı
anlatacağım ama
bir aydınlanma olacak
bilmeyen arkadaşlarım
içinde
bakın true
peki artık
ben tekrar
eski state'ine
getirene kadar
şimdi hep
true false olarak
mı yazacak
tabi ki
o zaman şöyle bir
soru gündeme
geliyor
peki
ben nasıl o bayrağı
tekrar
reset edeceğim
son derece
basit
bu sefer de
arka planda
arkadaşlar
aynı maskenin
bitsel değilini
V işlemiyle
kullanan
aset
F fonksiyonu var
yani maskenin
bitsel değilini
almaktan
siz sorumlu
değilsiniz
siz sadece
set F yerine
aset F fonksiyonuna
aynı maskeyi
gideceksiniz
şimdi yine
hangi state'e
geldi
olarak
yazacak
state'e
geldi
bakın
gördünüz mü
burayı anladık mı
şimdi arka planda
bu nasıl yapılıyor
bir şey göstereceğim
çok dikkatli izleyin
aslında
stream nesnelerinin
FMT flex türünden
sınıfı biz yazsaydık
bir data memberi var
değil mi
tabi ki
non-static
data member
peki
onu get etmek
mümkün mü
cevap
evet
sınıfın
flex isimli
bir fonksiyonu var
çok dikkatli izleyin
şimdi burası çok çok önemli
sınıfın
flex fonksiyonu
FMT flex
değerini
get ediyor
yani
şimdi ben
bu fonksiyonu çağırdığımda
bu fonksiyonun
geri dönüş
değeri
türü ne
FMT flex
bana neyi
veriyor
FMT flex
türünden
format state'i
veriyor
şimdi o zaman
soruyu çok dikkatli izleyin
sizden
şöyle bir şey istediler
elinizde
bir
o stream
nesnesi var
örneğin
see out
ama
en son
yapılan işlemlerin
ne olduğunu
bilmiyorsunuz
bunun format
state'i
boolean değeri
0-1 olarak
yazdıracak
şekilde de
olabilir
profiles olarak
yazdıracak
şekilde de
olabilir
peki bunu
nasıl yet edeceğiz
ya son derece
basit
bir bitin
1 mi
0 mı
olduğunu
nasıl anlarız
maskeyle
v işlemine
sokup
lojik
yorumlama
yaparız
değil mi
o zaman
ben şöyle bir
if deyimi
yazsam
if
see out
flex
bitsel ve
ios'un
ios base'in
nesi
full alfası
o zaman
if'in doğru
kısmına girerse
umarım takip
edebiliyorsunuz
if'in doğru
kısmına girerse
true false
olarak yazacak
durumda
değil mi
hatta onu
yazdıralım
bakın
see out
true
false
ama
else durumunda
arkadaşlar
0-1
peki
default
durumu
neydi
kv
0-1
dedi
değil mi
bakın
şimdi
peki
ben burada
setf fonksiyonunu
çağırmış
olsaydım
see out
setf
buna
ios
base'in
bool alfası
maskesini
argüman olarak
geçseydim
state'i değişmiş
olacaktı
değil mi
şimdi bu
kod çalıştığında
ben
bool alfabetini
get ettiğimde
onun 1 olduğunu
göreceğim
dolayısıyla
if'in
doğru kısmına
girdi
burayı
herkes anladı mı
evet
ya da
burada
tekrar
ansetf fonksiyonunu
çağırsaydım
ve ansetf fonksiyonuna
çağrı yaptıktan
sonra
ul alfabetini
teknik tabiriyle
get etseydim
yine
0-1
olacaktı
değil mi
herkes anladı mı
arkadaşlar
şimdi çok dikkatli
izleyin
asıl espriye
bakın
flex fonksiyonunun
bir overloadu
daha var
flex fonksiyonuna
eğer siz
bir
fmt
flex
değeri
verirseniz
bu durumda
doğrudan
o
değişkene
o değeri
atıyor
bu da şu
demek
bakın
bakalım
anlayabilecek
misiniz
siya
alt nokta
setf
ios
base
bool alfa
demekle
ne demek
aynı anlamda
şimdi şaşıracaksınız
siya
alt
arkadaşlar
flex
buraya bakın
siya
alt
flex
takip edebiliyor muyuz
veya
ios
arkadaşlar
base'in
bool alfası
şimdi ben bunu yazdığım zaman
bilsel işlemler konusunda
bilgi sahibi olmayan arkadaşlar
biraz şaşırıyor
ama koda bakıp
anlamaya çalışın
necat ben anlamadım
ne yapmak istediğini
tekrar söyleyeyim
şimdi anlayacaksınız
soruyu
anlamaya çalışın
15. satırdaki fonksiyon
çağrısıyla
16. satırdaki fonksiyon
çağrısı
tamamen
aynı işini yapıyor
cevap
evet
neden
bakın
bakın burada
format state'i
get ettim
ama onu
bool alfayla
bitsel
veya işlemine
soktum
ama yeni
değer olarak da
yazdım
bravo
deniz tam
ifadesini
yazmış
diyor ki
bool alfa
bit değerini
orlayıp
aslında aktif ediyor
değil mi
evet
işte yukarıdaki fonksiyon
aslında bunu yapıyor
peki
şimdi soruya cevap verin
bakalım
bu durumda
tamamen
anladığınızı
ben anlayacağım
şimdi söyleyin bakalım
anset f fonksiyonu
olmasaydı
sadece
flex fonksiyonu
olsaydı
flex fonksiyonuna
çağrı yaparak
anset f
işlemini
nasıl yapardım
v ile
ama
bir farkla
Alihan
Kaan Can
Bayrağın
bravo
Oğuzhan Bey
tabi ki bayrağın
bitsel
değilini
kullanarak
işte anset f
nin karşılığı
da ne
siyahat
flex
bitsel
arkadaşlar
ve
bitsel ve
ama
maskemizin
bitsel
değili
bakın
burayı anlamanız
önemli
basit
ama
biraz bitsel
işlem bilmek
gerekiyor
bu set f
ile aşağıdaki
flex çağrısı
aynı
bu anset f
ile
aşağıdaki
flex çağrısı
aynı
anlaşıldı mı
o zaman
benim
böyle uzun uzun
bir fonksiyon
çağrısı yapmam
yerine
şunu yazmam
yeterli
aşağıdaki fonksiyon
çağrısı yerine
bunu yazmam
yeterli
arkadaşlar
şimdi ben size
şöyle bir soru
sorsam
bakın şimdi
çok
dikkatli izleyin
ben size şöyle bir
soru sorsam
desem ki
bitsel
veya işleminde
ben
birden fazla
maskeyi
bitsel
veya
operatörüyle
işleme
soksam
mesela
oyos
base'in
uppercase'i
arkadaşlar
veya
oyos
base'in
arkadaşlar
show
postu
veya
bitsel
tabi
oyos
base'in
örneğin
show
point'i
şimdi söyler
misiniz
bana
bu durumda
bu bayrakların
bu
sabitlerin
hepsi
bir biti
bir
diğer bitleri
sıfır olan
maskelerse
o zaman
bu sabit
nedir
mecate dalga mı
geçiyorsun
üç biti bir
diğer bitleri
sıfırdır
o zaman
ben
set f
fonksiyonuna
see out
set f
bu argümanı
geçersem
arkadaşlar
şurada underscore
yok
niye underscore
koymuşsam
bu argümanı
geçersem
bu durumda
üç tane
birden
bayrağı
set etmiş
olurum
değil mi
peki
alihan
o zaman
cevabınızın
devamını da
getirin
bu durumda
artık benim
siyahat
nesnem
nasıl bir
format
state'e
kavuştu
eksatesimal
yazarken
büyük harfle
yazacak
öyle değil mi
hatta bir tane daha
yazalım
bakın
ios
base'in
arkadaşlar
nesi
show
base'i
show base'i
yazmamışım
bakın
böyle yazarsam
ne olacak
cevap
dört tane
bayrağı
birden
set etmiş
olacağım
şimdi söyleyin
bakalım
isterseniz
bakın
see out
ama
bir de yukarıdakine
bakın
default'ta
tabii ki
show post yok
yani sadece
12 yazacak
ama
16. satırdaki
set f çağrısından
sonra
pozitif değerleri
yazarken
artı gösterirsin
mi
bayrağını
true hale getirdim
bir yaptım
öyle yazdı
şimdi
şurayı görmeyin
arkadaşlar
burayı görmeyin
buraya ayrıca anlatacağım
mesela
bakınız
şimdi
izleyin
ne olsun
işte
76.234
arkadaşlar
iki yazım arasındaki
farka bakın
hexadecimal yazarken
ön iki göstermedi
harfler küçük
ama
format state'i
değiştirdiğimde
bakın
show base'i aktif hale
getirdiğim için
0x
uppercase'i aktif hale
getirdiğim için
x büyük
ca büyük
yani
birden fazla
on off bayrağını
set etmek
ya da
reset etmek için
set f fonksiyonuna
ya da
unset f fonksiyonuna
bunları
ne olarak
geçebilirim
arkadaşlar
bu maskeleri
bitsel veya
operatörlüğe
birleştirerek
tek bir argüman
olarak
geçebilirim
burayı anladık mı
buraya kadar
anlamadığımız bir şey
var mı
güzel
devam o zaman
şimdi
on off bayraklarının
hikayesi böyle
ama
bütün bayraklar
bütün formatlama
özellikleri
on off bayraklarıyla
yani
ya true
ya false
temsil edilemez
mesela
sayı sistemi
arkadaşlar
şimdi burada
enteresan
bir durum var
burayı
yine bitsel işlemlere
geri dönerek
anlatmam
gerekiyor
örneğimizi
ne üstünden
verelim
sayı sistemi
üstünden
verelim
arkadaşlar
üç tane
sayı sistemi var
hex
octal
yani
sekizlik
sayı sistemi
ve decimal
lütfen takip etmeye
çalışın
aslında
bunlar
ardışık
bitler
yani örneğin
şu bitler
olsun
şimdi
diyelim ki
bu bitlerden
biri
hexadecimal
diğeri
oktal
decimal
o zaman
ben bunları
şu sabitleri
yazdırırsam
yine bunlar
bitsel maskeler
yani
ayos
beysin
teksi
ayos
beysin
oktu
ve
ayos
beysindeki
yine
sıfır
bir
bir biti
diğer bitleri
sıfır
olan maskeler
olacak değil mi?
kesinlikle
ama şimdi
şöyle bir şey var
burayı çok dikkatli
izleyin
ben örneğin
hexadecimal
sayı
sisteminde
yazsın diye
hex bitini
birlersem
ne olur?
arkadaşlar
diğer bitler de
bir
olabilir
bu durumda
böyle bir
işlemi yapmam
için
bu biti
bir yapmam
yetmez
değil mi?
aynı zamanda
bu iki
biti de
sıfırlamam
gerekir
yani
ancak
bu bitleri
şu hale
getirirsem
istediğime
kavuşurum
burayı
anladınız mı?
dolayısıyla
bu tür
formatlama
özellikleri
söz konusu
olduğunda
biz yine
set f
fonksiyonunu
çağırıyoruz
ama set f
fonksiyonuna
iki tane
değer geçiyoruz
biri aslında
diyelim ki
hex yapmak için
şu maske
biri de
arkadaşlar
bakınız
burayı
sıfırlamak için
kullanılacak
şu maske
dolayısıyla
yine
set f
fonksiyonunu
çağırıyoruz
fakat
set f
fonksiyonunun
iki parametreli
overloadunu
çağırıyoruz
burada
bu overloadun
bir parametresi
durum bayrağını
alacak
diğer parametresi
ben buna
alan bayrağı
diyorum
Türkçe'de
alan bayrağlarını
alacak
işte burada
bu değerlerde
şöyle
IOS
base'in
üç tane
sayı sistemi
için
üç tane
sabiti var
bunlar yine
fmt
flex türünden
IOS
base'in
heksi
deki
ve
octo
ama bakın
şu üç biti
kıpırlamak amaçlı
kullanılacak da
bir de
IOS
base'in
arkadaşlar
maske alan bayrağı
base field'i var
takip edebiliyor muyuz
evet
yani biz
set f
fonksiyonuna
örneğin
hexadecimal sayı
sisteminde
yazması için
stream'e
bu maskeyi
birinci parametresine
alan bayrağını da
ikinci parametresine
geçeceğiz
isterseniz deneyelim
bakın
default'u
değer
int
i var
eşittir
taşma olmasın
evet
milyon
bin
bakın şimdi
siya
i var
eşittir
Türkçe okuyorum
evet
ama şimdi bakın
siya
od
set f
arkadaşlar
görüyorsunuz
değil mi
şu overload'dan
bahsediyorum
arkadaşlar
birinci parametresine
IOS
base'in
hex'ini
ikinci parametresine
IOS base'in
base field'ini
geçiyorum
IOS yazmışım
aynı şey
IOS base'in
base field
takip edebiliyor muyuz
şimdi bakın
yine i var
yazdırıyorum
gördünüz değil mi
16'lık sayı
istemi
ben de öyle bir
sayı seçmişim ki
sadece bir karakter
her karakteri
biraz değiştirelim
arkadaşlar
milyon
bin
evet
görüyorsunuz
8cc
ft3
peki
octal'e geçeyim
IOS base'in
octu
burayı anladık mı
burayı
burayı herkes anladı mı
şimdi yine yazdırıyorum
arkadaşlar
hangi sayı
sisteminde yazacak
8'lik sayı
en üstteki
10'luk sayı
sistemi
alttaki
16'lık
bu
8'lik sayı
sistemi
anlaşıldı mı
evet
yalnız
burada
tam da
bir konudan
bahsetmenin
zamanı
şimdiye kadar
ben hep
IOS base'i kullandım
arkadaşlar
bakınız
çok dikkatli izleyin
aslında
sınıflar şöyleydi
değil mi
en tepedeki sınıf
neydi
benim soruma cevap verin
şimdi
IOS base
onun altındaki
neydi
basic IOS
peki
template mi
evet
IOS base template mi
hayır
takip edebiliyor muyuz
peki
o zaman
ben
basic IOS
diyemem
mesela
basic IOS'un
arkadaşlar
FMT
flex'i
diyemem
neden
e çünkü bu
template
ancak
ne diyebilirim
basic IOS'un
çar açılımının
FMT
flex'i
diyebilirim
Kaan Can
burayı anladık mı
ama şimdi
burada bir
sürpriz var
basic IOS'un
çar açılımının
type aliası
yani
türeş ismi
IOS
bu da ne demek
benim
IOS base'in
hex'i dememle
IOS'un
hex'i demem
arasında
hiçbir fark yok
eğer
çar açılımını
kullanıyorsam
o yüzden
kodların
çoğunda
programcıların
bu maskeleri
ve
FMT
flex
türünü
kullanmak
durumunda
ne yaptıklarını
göreceksiniz
bazıları
IOS base'in
hex'i yazar
ama
IOS'un hex'i
yazmakta
aynı anlamda
burayı anladık mı
evet
şimdi Alihan'ın
sorusuna bakalım
base field
kullanmadan
hex ve octu
set edersem
undefined
behavior mi
oluyor
arkadaşlar
çok güzel bir
soru
hemen söyleyeyim
bunların hepsi
standartta yazılı
mesela
böyle bir durumda
yanlış hatırlamıyorsam
undefined
behavior değil
cpp
referansdan
bakabilirsiniz
yine deck yazıyor
benim hatırladığım
o
yani arkadaşımın
sorusu son derece
önemli
ben
%100
hafızada
yaşlılıkta
biraz kötüleşiyor ya
%100 emin
değilsem
%99 bile
emin olsam
bir rezerv payı
bırakıyorum
o durum
benim hatırladığım
kadarıyla
undefined
behavior
değil
deck yazıyordu
ama
küçük bir ihtimalle
yanılıyor
olabilirim
tabi ki
burada
çalıştırdığım
zaman
benim
doğru söylediğim
kanıtlanmaz
çünkü
undefined
behavior
da benim
beklentimi
karşılayabilir
ama yine de
yazacağım
bakınız
gidip şöyle bir
kod yazayım
ios'un
arkadaşlar
cout'un
setf'si
ve
ios'un
hex'i
aslında
şu anda
hem deck bitini
hem hex bitini
set etmiş durumdayım
değil mi
öyle değil mi
evet
ama bakın
cout
ibar
ben de
yanlış hatırlıyor olayım
tanımsız davranış mı
siz de
cppreference.com'dan
bakabilirsiniz
tanımsız davranış
değil diye hatırlıyorum
bakın benim dediğim gibi oldu
değil mi
kimse olmuştu
Alihan
halen
deck yazdı
yos'un kitabında da
ayrıntısını veriyor
ama siz tabi
böyle yazmayın
yani
önemli olan
ne istiyorsanız
o format siteye de
getirmek
şimdi devam ediyoruz
arkadaşlar
o zaman
deck
hex
oct
nasıl belirleniyor
bunu gördük
arkadaşlar
şimdi ikinci
alan bayrağı
bu arada
hemen şunu da söyleyelim
araya sürekli bir şeyler
sokuyorum ama
arkadaşlar
c++'ın
en çok
eleştirilen
kütüphanesi
iostream
bir kere
olması
gerekenden
çok daha
hantal
tam anlamıyla
hantal sözcüğünün
belki ana dili
Türkçe olmayan
arkadaşlar
anlamını
bilmiyor
olabilir
yani
ağır
böyle hantal
insan nedir
yavaş yavaş
hareket eder
ağır
o yüzden
zaten
formatlama
tarafında
bu anlattıklarımı
bilmenizde
büyük fayda var
ama
daha çok
artık
c++
20 standardıyla
stud format
kütüphanesi
kullanılıyor
çünkü
stud format
kütüphanesi
çok daha
hızlı
formatlama
işlemlerinde
ben
maalesef
stud format
kütüphanesini
ayrıntılı
anlatıyorum
ama
yine
ileri
sivvas
bas
kursunu
anlatıyorum
burada
süre yetmediği
için
şimdi
efendim
bir başka
önemli
formatlama
özelliğine
geleceğiz
arkadaşlar
çok dikkatli
izleyin
yazma
alanı
genişliği
ingilizce'de
bu formatlama
özelliğine
ingilizce'de
output
read
deniyor
arkadaşlar
şimdi
output
biti
çok iyi
anlamanız
gerekiyor
ilk defa
tanışanlar için
söylüyorum
bu
en önemli
formatlama
özelliklerinden
biri
mesela
izleyin
diyelim ki
sizin
ilk türden
değişkenleriniz
yani
değerleriniz
ayrıca
isim
olarak
temsil edilen
yazılarınız
var
eğer siz
şöyle yazdırırsanız
bir boşluk
verdim
Muhammed
isim
bir boşluk
verdim
Hakan
efendim
bir boşluk
verdim
Selenay
arkadaşlar
kimsenin
hoşuna gitmez
böyle bir şeyi
okumak
değil mi
ne isterseniz
ya bunlar
aligned olsun
mesela
bunlar aynı
izada olsun
bunu
sağlamak
için
işte
output
biti
kullanıyoruz
output
bit şu
demek
çıkış
alanı
genişliği
örneğin
output
bit
8 ise
bir tam sayı
bu
arkadaşlar
tam sayı
değeri
ne olursa
olsun
ya da
gerçek sayı
onu ayrıca
konuşmamız
gerekiyor
8 karakterlik
alana
yazacak
yani
şimdi ben
nokta
yazacağım
ama
siz noktayı
görmemiş
olan
böyle
takip edebiliyor muyuz
12'yi
nasıl yazacak
böyle
sadece
beni dinleyin
ilk defa
tanışanlar
bilen arkadaşlarım
hiç
dinlemelerine
gerek yok
ama yine de
kulaklarını da
kapamasınlar
arkadaşlar
şimdi output
bitin
C'de de
C++'da da
bu dillerin
hemen hepsinde
şöyle bir özelliği var
bu dillerin
standart
kütüphanesi
output
bit
yazılacak
karakter
sayısından
daha azsa
bir etkisi
kalmaz
bu output
bitin
sıfır
olması
demektir
yani örneğin
benim yazacağım
değer
ise
iken
output
bit
2 ise
o zaman
sadece
87'i mi
yazacak
yoksa
8723'ü
mü
yazacak
cevap 8723'ü
anladınız değil mi
yani output
bit
daha düşük
değerde ise
bir önlemi
kalmıyor
ona output
bitin
sıfır
olması
deniyor
ve default
değeri
her zaman
output bitin
sıfır
olması
yani sıfır
olduğu zaman
kaç karakterse
onu yazacak
buraya kadar
takip edebildik mi
biraz zorlaşacak
çünkü
şimdi output
bitin
output bit
formatlama
özelliğinin
hayatımıza
girmesini
arkadaşlar bunları
öğrenmekte
fayda var
bir tek
cdc
plus
da yok ki
bütün
programlama
dillerinin
giriş çıkış
kütüphanelerinde
bu kavramlar
karşınıza
çıkacak
ilk defa
tanışanlar
için
söylüyorum
output bit
ile beraber
iki tane
daha
önemli
formatlama
özelliği
geliyor
birincisi
arkadaşlar
İngilizce
karşılığıyla
field
karakter
şimdi
ben bunu
Türkçe'de
doldurma
karakteri
diyorum
az önceki
örneğe
geri dönelim
output bit
peki
yazılacak
değerler de
bunlar
peki
4 tane
karakter
fazla geldi
buraya ne
koyacak
Necati
boşluk
karakteri
koyması
gerekmez mi
işte eğer
boşluk
karakteri
koyacaksa
field karakter
space
karakteri
yani
askideki
32'nin
oğlu
karakter
ama siz
field karakteri
nokta
karakteri
yazarsanız
yaparsanız
yani format
state'i o şekilde
değiştirirseniz
böyle yazacak
efendim
burada
diyelim ki
dolar
karakteri
yaparsanız
field karakteri
dolarla
dolduracak
burayı anladık mı
field karakterin
ne olduğunu
yani
kullanılmayan
alana
basılacak
karakter
ne
herkes anladı mı
evet
ama
bir önemli
özellik var
daha var
output fitle
ilgili
bunu herkes
tahmin ediyor
ama burada
eskiden
günümüze
kadar gelen
kütüphanemizin
büyük bir
ayıbı var
alignment
arkadaşlar
yani
yazma alanı
genişliğinde
genişliği
içinde
sola dayalımı
left aligned
sağ dayalı mı
right aligned
yoksa
arkadaşlar
hemen aklınıza
ne geliyor
ortalamalı mı
yazılsın
stud format
kütüphanesinde
gerçekten böyle
ama
affedersiniz
bu terimi
kullanmak
istemiyorum
ama
zamanda verilen
çok salakça
bir kararla
bu
oryentasyon
sola dayalı
var
sağa dayalı
ama
ortalama yok
ortalama
yerine
çok daha
az ihtiyaç
duyulacak
internal
denilen bir
seçenek var
şimdi bakın
sola dayalı
sağa dayalı
ne demek
onu
öğrenmeniz kolay
diyelim ki
arkadaşlar
buraya da
12 yapalım
ve sadece
şöyle gösterelim
diyelim ki
yazma alanı
genişliği
12 yazılacak
karakter sayısı
doldurma karakteri
nokta
bundan sonra da
başka bir şey
yazılmış olsun
Ahmet
pek söyleyin
bu
left aligned
mı
right aligned
neca dalga mı
geçiyorsun
tabi ki
sola dayalı
right aligned
olsaydı
nasıl olacaktı
o zaman
önce doldurma
karakterleri
olacaktı
arkadaşlar
sağa
dayalı
şekilde
yazılacaktı
peki
aslında
ihtiyaç duyulan
bunların dışında
ihtiyaç duyabilecek
en önemli
alignment özelliği
ne
ortalayarak
arkadaşlar
ortalasaydı da
şöyle bir şey
olacaktı
bakın format
kütüphanesi
böyle gerçekten
şöyle temsili
yazayım
saymadan
şöyle bir nokta
daha koyayım
burada
burayı anladık mı
peki
bizim şimdi
kütüphanemizde
left alignment
var mı
var
right alignment
var mı
var
bu var mı
yok
bunun yerine
internal
denilen
çok az ihtiyaç
duyulan bir seçenek
var
internalın ne olduğunu
biliyor musunuz
tahmin bile
edemezsiniz
çünkü çok az
ihtiyaç duyuluyor
o da şu
arkadaşlar
pozitif ve negatif
sembolleri yazılıyor
ya
artı
eksi
bakın bakın
işaretler
hizalanmış
sayılarda
bu şekilde
hizalanmış
internal bu
Allah için
bu mu daha çok
ihtiyaçtır
yoksa ortalama
mı daha
sık karşımıza
çıkan bir
ihtiyaçtır
tabii ki
ortalama
işte
stut format
kütüphanesinde
burada tercih olması
gerektiği gibi
yani
internal yok
ne var
arkadaşlar
ortalama var
ama bizde böyle
peki bu nasıl
yapılacak
yine aynı şekilde
arkadaşlar
IOSPACE'in
3 tane
maskesi var
biri
left
right
biri de
internal
dünyanın en saçma
peki
yine 3 tane
seçenek
olduğuna
Rasul diyor ki
peki bir
trik var mı
yapmak için
trik var
kendi formatlama
sitenizi
bu duruma
getirecek
bir kodu
yazabilirsiniz
onunla nasıl
yapıldığını
gösterir
anlaşıldı
değil mi
kendi
manipülatörümü
yazarak
bunu yapabilirim
ama
standart
olarak
yok
peki
burada bir de
ne gerekiyor
tıpkı
burada
IOSPACE'in
BASEFILD'ini
kullanmam gibi
bunun içinde bir
alan bayrağı
gerekiyor
değil mi
o da
ADJUSTFILD
IOSPACE'in
ADJUSTFILD'i
arkadaşlar
bakınız
izleyin
şimdi
output
biti
set etmek
ve get
etmek için
sınıfın
arkadaşlar
bit fonksiyonu
var
bit fonksiyonunun
parametresiz
olanı
get fonksiyonu
söyleyin
bakalım
bunlar
işaretsiz
tam sayı
döndürüyor
bit fonksiyonunu
şimdi çağırsam
geri dönüş
değeri kaç olacak
sizce
default'u ne
sıfır
bravo
bakınız
takip edebiliyor muyuz
evet
arkadaşlar
izleyin
ama
parametreli olan
eski değeri
bunlar hep böyledir
headset fonksiyonları
diyorum bunlara
eski değeri
get ediyor
yeni değeri
set ediyor
yani şöyle
bir kod
yazsam
auto
n
eşittir
cout bit
şimdi
output bit
kaç oldu
rasul
20 oldu
ama geri dönüş
değeri ne
geri dönüş
değeri
arkadaşlar
long long
push
burada tür
geri dönüş
değeri
yani eski
get ediyor
yeni değeri
set ediyor
yalnız
output bit
önemli bir özelliği var
kalıcı olmayan
tek formatlama özelliği bu
yani output bit
her yazımda
tekrar sıfıra çekiliyor
yani bakınız
mesela şöyle bir kod yazsam
see out
with
arkadaşlar
Ali
ondan sonra
Mehmet
ya da şöyle
sayı yazayım
daha iyi görürsün
hem Mehmet'i
hem de
değerini mi
yazma alanı
genişliğiyle
yazacak
yoksa sadece
cevap
sadece
necati peki
sola dayalı
sağa dayalı
bunun da
default var
default'u
belki tahmin edebilirsiniz
arkadaşlar
sağa dayalı
bakın default'ta
doldurma karakteri
space karakteri
yazma alanı
genişliği
sıfır
ve
sağa dayalı
şimdi
soru
o zaman
örneğin
bunu da ben
yine
farklı bir
yazma alanı
genişliğiyle
yazdırmak
isteseydim
3456'yı
yazdırdıktan
sonra
format state'i
tekrar değiştirmem
gerekirdi
ama şimdi
bakın
şu önce
alignment'ı
bir görelim
cout
setf
ios'un
left'i
adjust
filter
sadece
takip edin
oğuzhan'ın
sorusuna da
bakalım
hocam
sadece
formatlamak için
kullanmak istersek
string stream
üzerinden mi
yapardık
tam soruyu
belki
anlamamış
olabilirim
sadece
formatlamak için
kullanmak
istersek
derken
tam ne
kastediliyor
çıkışa basmak
istemiyorum
arkadaşlar
zaten
çıkışa basmanız
gerekmiyor ki
bakın
çıkışa basmanız
gerekmiyor ki
şu anda
ben sadece
format state'i
değiştirdim
daha çok
sanıyorum
soru şu
ben doğru
anladıysam
ben bunu
formatlı bir
yazı elde etmek
istersem
yani çıkışa
basmıyorum
ama
evet
o işte
string stream
sınıfları
orada da
3 tane
sınıf var
şimdi anladım
sorunuz
sorunuz yanlış
değil
ben anlamamışım
orada da
3 tane
sınıf var
o sınıfların
isimleri de
şöyle
o string stream
çıkış tarafı
için
i string stream
giriş tarafı
için
string stream
hem giriş
hem çıkış
tarafına
sahip
olanlar için
evet
bakınız
izleyin
şimdi tekrar
yazdırıyorum
cout
şimdi
sola dayalı
oldu
görüyorsunuz
değil mi
ama şöyle yazsaydım
ki defaultu bu
arkadaşlar
ios
right
and chance
field
sağa dayalı
ve tabi
internal
eğer
derleyici
implement
etmişse
izleyin
bakalım
benim derleyici
implement
etmiş mi
normalde
etmesi gerekiyor
tabi
şimdi
siyah
set
p
ios
un
show
postu
ios
un
internal
ios
sadece bu
olsun
yerlerini
silelim
şu
olsun
sanırım
istediğim
duruma
getirdim
evet
gördünüz
değil mi
bakın
artı
burada
sayılar
evet
bugün
buraya kadar
ilerledik
bir dahaki
hafta
kaldığımız yerden
devam edeceğiz
arkadaşlar
bir dahaki
hafta
eğer
hızlı
gidersek
oyun stream
kütüphanesinde
dosya işlemlerine
kadar
gelmeyi
planlıyorum
evet
peki
derse
katıldığınız için
teşekkür ediyorum
bir dahaki hafta
görüşmek üzere
herkese
iyi akşamlar
diliyorum
hoşçakalın
değerli arkadaşlar
ja
instagram
Bite